we will now begin tonight's take note
debate accordingly
mr trudeau moves that this committee
take note of the russian military forces
on ukraine
borders
debate the right honorable prime
minister
minister for foreign affairs canada has
always been clear about our steadfast
support for ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity
from being the first western country to
recognize ukraine's independence to the
deep partnership we've developed in the
years since
and to the expanded support our
government has announced in recent days
ukrainians have the right to determine
their future
canada alongside our allies will always
stand firm in defense of that right
when people elect a government when they
collectively choose a path forward
when they want to make progress
these democratic choices have to be
respected
for right now madam speaker
that is not what russia is doing
russia
is seeking confrontation
russian actions are once again standing
in direct opposition to democratic
principles
these actions are calling into question
the fundamental principles of
sovereignty and territorial integrity
enshrined in the un charter
that's why we must show unity and
resolve in standing with ukraine
that's why canada and its allies have
been clear that any further incursion
into ukraine will provoke severe costs
and serious consequences including the
imposition of coordinated sanctions
madam speaker we'll continue to be there
to provide support to ukraine
in 2015 canada launched operation
unifier a military training mission that
has helped train about 33 000 members of
the ukrainian security forces
last week i authorized the extension and
expansion of operation unifier as part
of this commitment the canadian armed
forces is deploying 60 personnel to join
the approximately 200 women and men
already on the ground with further
capacity to increase the number of
people up to 400.
we're also sending additional support in
the form of non-lethal equipment
intelligence sharing and help to combat
cyber attacks
come on
i want to take this
foreign
they do exemplary madam speaker canada
has a long history of standing up to
bullies
but standing up to bullies doesn't mean
that we want conflict let's be clear
about the facts
nato is no threat to russia it's a
defensive alliance built on the free
choice of its members to support each
other in collective security ukraine is
not provoking russia or threatening its
security
in the days and weeks to come we'll
continue coordinating closely with
ukraine nato allies and our other
international partners to stand firm in
support of ukraine and to deter further
russian aggression
the fate of ukraine matters to the world
and to canadians i've made this very
clear including directly to president
zielinski i've defended the rights of
ukrainians to choose their own future in
the past with organizations like the g7
and nato and i'll continue to do so
we are always stronger together
and we won't
be intimidated
thank you madam speakers and comments
the honorable member for selkirk
interlake eastman
thank you madam chair and uh
honorable stan tonight in this debate on
the future of ukraine's uh ability to
protect itself and you know i appreciate
the comments made by the prime minister
but at the same time we know madam
speaker that
it was
ukraine's biggest demand of nato allies
including canada for the last four or
five years is to beef up its lethal
defensive weapons knowing that at any
moment russia may want to invade ukraine
so now we have over a hundred thousand
russian troops standing on ukraine's
borders on the north on the east and
down
in the south virtually he's got ukraine
surrounded and
i know that president zielinski and uh
the embassy here in ukraine has been
asking the government of canada to
provide lethal weapons
the prime minister has been completely
mute on this why hasn't he supplied
lethal weapons to
ukraine is it going to wait until russia
invades ukraine by then it's too late
right honorable prime minister
i thank the uh honourable member for his
question and i will point out
that canada has been steadfast in its
support of ukraine and that's why we
have engaged directly with ukraine and
ukraine's leadership to hear uh what
they need the number one ask from
president zielenski was economic
supports which we delivered in a 120
million dollar sovereign loan to help
them counter the economic
destabilization that russia is engaging
in
and their other ask indeed
is preoccupation with their ability to
defend ukraine's territorial integrity
well on that we have responded we have
responded by
extending and
enlarging
canada's extraordinarily successful
mission that directly trains up 30 has
trained up 33 000 members of the
ukrainian defense forces and continues
to be one of the uh most impactful and
positive uh
elements of nato's support for ukraine
canada will always be there for ukraine
but we will respond to their asks in a
way that responds to their priorities
that's what friends don't have a member
is
the propaganda
[Music]
for a foreign solution but we are also
indicating that there are serious
consequences for russia
if there is uh
congressional once again towards the
territorial integrity of ukraine and the
people no no the honourable member for
edmonton stratton
ask the member um what he is doing what
his government is doing to ensure that
the feminist foreign policy is front and
center as as we deal with this current
crisis in ukraine and what is his
government doing to ensure that women
are at all negotiating tables uh right
now that the canadian government is
advocating for women to be present and
to be to be at all of those tables at
this time if you could answer that that
would be great
the right honorable prime minister
i'm
pleased to underline that it is a
continued preoccupation of this
government to have a feminist foreign
policy which is certainly something uh
that our
minister of foreign affairs milanese ali
is actively engaged in uh in terms of
concretely on the ground when i was last
in ukraine i engaged directly with
members of civil society to talk about
how canada was supporting uh various uh
actors to uh encourage uh a full uh uh a
full uh gender equality in their
approach uh we also have specific
measures within operation unifier in
training uh that addresses gender issues
we will continue to make sure that that
path to peace includes women because we
know
from
countless examples around the world that
women are key
to solving uh long-term conflicts and
making sure they stay solved
resuming debate representatives
[Applause]
the facts are simple madam speakers as
we speak yes
there are a hundred thousand russian
troops
along the border of ukraine
they have tanks missiles there are
troops and they're ready to go on the
offensive
will of the ukrainian people
in article foreign
of the un charter the respect of
sovereignty and independence it states
u.n members should refrain from threat
or use of force against the territorial
integrity or political independence
of any state
the russian government claims they value
the u.n charter
they need to show it
de-escalate
canada's resolute in supporting ukraine
sovereignty territorial integrity and
independence
we stand with ukrainians and we're
absolutely committed to a diplomatic
solution
we are a country that has a
long-standing diplomatic history
we're the ones that can bridge different
countries together
friends
to the united states
but also we're friends to europe
we're more than one point far we have
more than 1.4 ukrainian canadians here
in canada and we understand ukraine
since my appointment working on a
diplomatic solution has been my top
priority
i've had extensive conversation on this
matter with my counterparts around the
world
in washington riga stockholm liverpool
kiev paris and brussels
and of course right here in ottawa and
with many members of this house
in my recent trip i had productive
meetings
with the leadership of ukraine the
president the prime minister the deputy
prime minister and the minister of
foreign affairs
with the leadership of the european
union the president of the council and
the foreign affairs minister and also
with the secretary general of nato
i had all so good meetings with the
foreign ministers of france belgium and
constructive conversation with us
secretary blinken as well as germany's
minister bearbook
and just today i spoke to my
counterparts in denmark netherlands and
latvia
we all agree de-escalation is key and it
is urgent
russia's oppressive actions are
threatening global stability in that
sense ukraine security is just is is not
only europe's security it is the world
security including ours here right here
at home
in canada
now is a time to be united
now is the time to speak with one voice
in support of ukraine and its people
we also need to invest in deterrence
sanctions economic support for ukraine
and
and expanding operation unifier are our
immediate actions
on sanctions
any further aggression will have serious
consequences included
including courted
economic sanctions with allies and
canada is ready
stability economic
supports ukraine with financial aid to
ensure the stability of his country
shortly after our announcement the eu
announced that they would in turn
provide two
um
ukrainian soldiers
since 2014
of the ukrainian armed forces in
addition to military development and and
financial assistance canada's diplomatic
service continue to work around the
clock
to support the canadian effort we are
increasing diplomatic resources in kiev
it is important to support civil society
efforts as well in these difficult times
[Applause]
the honourable member for selkirk into
lake eastman
thank you mr speaker and i want to thank
the mr foreign affairs for her speech
but i have to say that it's been
incredibly disappointing to see
her trip to ukraine where she went over
empty-handed
she did after her return
did announce 120 million dollars of
financial assistance which i know is
welcome but we know for a fact that
there has been demands from the
government of ukraine for the last
several years for more military help
including
the
use of or provision of lethal weapons we
know that one of the very first things
that this
liberal government did when they came to
power several years ago back in
2016 is that they stopped the provision
of radar assad images so the people of
ukraine the government ukraine could
actually see what the russian forces
were doing in places like crimea and
donbass which is sovereign ukraine
territory but now legally occupied by
the russian federation
when will the minister actually provide
the kinetic energy and the military
might that's required for ukraine to
defend off this potential russian
invasion when will they provide those
lethal weapons
when will they restore the use of radar
sat images which are are you know world
renowned and ones that would really help
with the security situation on the
ground and will they actually stand with
ukraine rather than just offer
empty rhetoric and half measures
the honourable minister of foreign
affairs
well
my colleague and i don't agree on
everything we agree on the fact that we
need to make sure that there's no
further invasion of ukraine
but right now the most important thing
we need to do is to make sure that we
invest in diplomacy and deterrence and
that's exactly what we're doing mr
speaker what we're doing right now is
that we're really that country that is
bridging all the other countries of the
alliance together and making sure that
there's strong unity which is the case
and also we are specialists of ukraine
because as my colleague himself of
ukrainian descent
we have 1.4 million ukrainian canadians
in canada and therefore we can make sure
that people know about ukraine even
within the alliance of nato
on the question of deterrence ukrainian
ukraine needed support financially we
were there
within three days with a a loan of 120
million dollars ukraine
wanted more support in terms of military
training we were there within a week
and ukraine also wanted more support in
terms of cyber
support and we were there also within a
week and for all that president
zielinski himself said to prime minister
trudeau and this government
thank you
before moving on i just want to remind
the honourable members when we're
speaking of someone we talk of their
title not of their names just to make
is
is
is
um
officials
is
foreign
is
[Music]
is
that divides nato members
the honorable leader of the opposition
[Applause]
mr speaker i stand in this house saying
that we stand
with ukraine here an important friend
and ally of canada
important not just to the 1.4 million
canadians
with ukrainian ancestry
important to every single canadian in
this country
because ukraine is our friend
our trading partner
and our ally
this is a debate not about hashtags
or holding a sign up on twitter mr
speaker as the minister and the liberal
government have done this is a debate
about who canadians are
as a friend on the world stage this is a
debate
about our values
as a nation
the dependability of canada as an ally
from vimy ridge mr speaker to kandahar
to all points in between to the dawn
bass today
is canada that friend
an ally
that the world knows
is canada living up
to its reputation as a founding
member of nato is canada living up to
the fact that nato
would not have been formed but for the
role that canada played
bridging the atlantic nations in world
war ii as winston churchill described us
mr speaker the linchpin
between the free peoples of europe
and of north america
ukrainian canadians are demanding more
from this government than hashtags
canadians and indeed our allies and
friends around the world are asking for
more than hollow
words
and empty gestures mr speaker you can
send as many ministers to kiev
as you wish
but if they come with nothing but hollow
words
as we evacuate our people mr speaker
that is letting our friends down
it's also letting our country down for
its values
the politics
of canada
repositions
from vimy ridge to today mr speaker
canada has known to be there
for our friends for our allies but also
for our values of liberty freedom and
dignity of person mr speaker these are
values we have fought and died for
and ukrainian canadians have built this
great country there's members on both
sides of this house
the first governor general the great
reynation former conservative member of
parliament the first
cabinet minister of ukrainian extraction
i met because he's from my area michael
starr mr speaker the former mp for
oshawa
my first event
as a aspiring politician was at levitt
hall
with my ukrainian canadian friends in
oshawa my friend from selkirk interlake
eastman my wingman of late
introduced holodomor
commemoration in this house one of the
first western parliaments to talk about
the horrific famine
brought on the ukrainian people by
the
russian uh uh overlords at the time mr
speaker by the soviet union
by a neighbor that has always impinged
on the freedoms of ukrainians and it's
up to us as canadians to be there now
for them
in fact i had the honor mr speaker in
2014 to be in this chamber
for a speech from president poroshenko
the president of ukraine who was invited
to speak about that friendship between
our two countries and he said this quote
today thousands of brave ukrainian men
and women are sacrificing their lives
for the right to live in the way they
choose on their land under the blue and
gold colors of the ukrainian flag colors
that are so dear to many canadian
ukrainians in these dark days we feel
your strong support
thank you very much for that he went on
to say mr speaker
it is in our time of need that we need
to see our friends
and there is no other way to put it
canada is a friend indeed end quote
now
prime minister diefenbaker challenged
russia to allow free elections for
ukrainians it was the mulroney
conservative government that was the
first
ally to recognize the independent
ukraine it was prime minister harper who
famously after the invasion of crimea
said to vladimir putin get out of
ukraine
and what do we have from this prime
minister mr speaker
we have hashtags
we have ministers embarrassingly
holding up a sign on twitter
that is what canada is known for now mr
speaker
twitter diplomacy
but not standing with our nato allies in
fact everything that's been done in the
last decade for our allies and friends
in ukraine were initiated by
conservative governments mr speaker
operation reassurance operation unifier
the use of radar sat images which they
removed a few years ago mr speaker
military equipment
all of those measures in fact we have to
push
to get this government to extend
operation unifier they waited to the
very last minute
and the ukrainian government
including their former ambassador just
this weekend they've been asking
for lethal defensive weapons
why mr speaker because here's what
they're facing there are citizens in
ukraine today being trained how to use a
rifle being trained
on hand-to-hand combat this is something
we're so fortunate canadians we don't
ever have to worry about
there are 130 000 troops lining up
60 battalions tactical groups the
russians are lying on the border
russia outnumbers ukraine four to one in
military personnel 22 to 1
in fighter planes 15-1 in attack
helicopters and five to one in battle
tanks mr speaker
they're asking for our help at their
hour of need
and other allies have responded the us
the uk poland lithuania latvia estonia
czech republic
where is canada mr speaker
when our friend when our ally is in need
where is canada
von creek
is
the world is watching
this is not a time for twitter this is
not a time
for hollow words and rhetoric
there is a real chance
that there could be an invasion
of ukraine by russia
mr putin has shown his callous disregard
for ta sovereign territory
we've seen in crimea the phony war in
the dawn bass
the influence the cyber attacks the
shutting down of the hydro grid
the bad actor of the world needs to be
called out and nato is doing that but
one of the founding countries of nato
canada
is missing in action mr speaker so this
is an issue that i'm sure many
in the liberal government wish they were
doing more than just brief trips over
there to say hello
i'm sure many are wishing they were
responding to their quest
of our ally at their hour of need
canada
may be a smaller nation
having served in uniform myself mr
speaker i know we don't have the
standing armies we don't have
the the fleets of fighter jets
but we have a passion in our glowing
hearts that we were always
there for our friends and values
from the earliest days before our
american friend
as lester b pearson once said mr speaker
a liberal prime minister
that if a rifle is fired on the korean
peninsula or in europe it's just as
important to defend canada as if it was
done here on our own soil mr speaker
so this government has a choice
while there's time left
step up
and help our friends in ukraine step up
with the equipment they say they need to
fight against overwhelming odds and show
the world canada remains a friend and
ally there through thick and thin mr
speaker
questions and comments
foreign affairs
thank you mr speaker
it's not because
my colleague
and the leader of the opposition states
facts
that necessarily
they're true that's right
and in that sense
our actions have been clear 120 million
dollars for a summer in long first
second doubling the troops of operation
unifier in ukraine does he know that we
have the biggest foreign military
training presence in ukraine as of now
does he know that canadians right now
are standing shoulder to shoulder in
kiev and in 13 different places around
ukraine
does he know
that secretary general of nato
jens stoltenberg said canada is one of
the lead countries in nato when it comes
to providing support for ukraine and he
also added that there are not many other
countries at the equal level of efforts
doing as much as canada
so he talks about
the great flowing hearts of our calf
members and i agree with him
but the reality is is that they're the
ones and we're the ones right now in
ukraine what does he have to say about
that
the honorable leader of the opposition
mr speaker i'd like to thank the
minister for intervention
where she asked if i knew the facts
yes i do mr speaker in fact
operation reassurance operation unifier
sharing of military intelligence
including radar sat
military equipment the training she
talked about the training we're both
very proud of our men and women in
uniform doing all of that mr speaker
was started by the conservative
government and only reluctantly
as that minister knows one of her
predecessors mr dion
actually withdrew some of that support
and wanted to
normalize relations with russia mr
speaker that was their foreign policy
out of the gate
but whether it's appeasement of russia
whether it's a completely out of touch
policy on the communist regime in china
mr speaker whether it's letting down our
nato allies whether it's not even
getting phone calls from the united
states anymore mr speaker
canada needs to step up and a loan is
important and i thank the minister for
the loan
but once ukrainians lose their liberty
and freedom we can't loan them the
freedom they will need we can't loan
them the military equipment when the
attack is underway so i urge the
minister do the right thing and give the
ukrainians the tools they need to defend
themselves
questions in the comments because
foreign
uh
foreign
[Applause]
edmonton strathcona thank you mr speaker
i'd like to thank the the member
opposite for his comments today you know
one of the things that bothers me most
about his comments today is that he
speaks about lethal force he speaks
about action but i don't hear him
talking about diplomacy i don't hear him
talking about using what we can to
de-escalate this situation right now and
what i want him to understand is that it
is ukrainian people who will die if
there is a war in ukraine it is women
and children in ukraine who will die if
we continue to escalate the situation
now this his government when they were
in power they were the ones that
decimated foreign aid they were the ones
that decimated our diplomatic corps so
perhaps he doesn't believe in diplomacy
perhaps he doesn't believe in sanctions
and the power of of the international
community to find a peaceful resolution
but i am wondering why he thinks someone
who will not have to go to war in
ukraine the war is such a wonderful idea
for the ukrainian people right now
the honorable leader of the opposition
mr speaker i think the member was
misstating the fact that i'm suggesting
war is a good thing mr speaker i'm
fortunate to be
a veteran that never had to serve in
afghanistan but i've seen
not only in my time in military my time
as veterans minister the incredible toll
war and conflict plays on our military
on civilian populations it is those very
ukrainians she talks about at risk that
are now
in legion halls in church basements
being trained on how to defend
themselves and all they want
is for their friends in canada to give
them some equipment so they don't have
to call out senior citizens to the front
lines mr speaker if you do not have
appropriate military counterbalance
which is why nato was created
you cannot engage strategically and
effectively in diplomacy we support
diplomacy it was raynell hendrick a
senator who brought magnitsky sanctions
to canada sponsored in this house by my
friend beside me from selkirk interlake
eastman mr speaker we should be using
sanctions we should be using pressure we
should be using diplomacy
but hollow commitments through social
media empower a dictator like vladimir
putin mr speaker we need to stand by our
allies and stand up for
ukraine
questions and comments
[Applause]
the honourable member for sherwood park
for saskatchewan thank you mr speaker
and i thank our leader for his remarks
uh he spoke briefly at the end there
about magnitsky sanctions and i wanted
to just follow up on that point what
i've been hearing from many experts is
the importance of using the magnitsky
act and specifically targeting those
kleptocrats who are investing vladimir
putin's money overseas i don't know
earth the leader has a comment on on
specifically targeting those kleptocrats
as a way of really getting at and having
real accountability for the putin regime
thank you very much mr speaker and i'd
like to thank my learned friend
for his commentary and for his advocacy
he is
absolutely right
not only is the putin regime putting
ukrainians at risk putting stability in
europe and indeed globally at risk
he's also
leading a kleptocracy that is robbing
russians of their ability to actually
build up their lives
he is through some oligarchs
and through a system of money laundering
throughout the world that we need to
work through fintrac and other agencies
with our allies to root out
using sanctions using pressure
to call these regimes what they are mr
speaker it should trouble the minister
that one of her mentors mr dion
was actually advocating rapprochement
with mr putin
after he invaded and occupied crimea
it was her government that withdrew
radar sat imaging so that ukrainians
could track russian movements in the
dawn bass mr speaker vladimir putin for
years has been plotting what he is doing
now
and the moment now is for us to give our
ally what they need and continue as my
friend said to apply magnitsky sanctions
to work diplomatically
but you have to make sure you have a
real stick to have diplomacy mr speaker
and right now our friends in ukraine are
asking canada to stand alongside the
united states the united kingdom poland
other allies to be there for ukraine
when they need us most they're here
[Applause]
questions and comments the honourable
member for etobicoke make sure i'm
afraid we only have time for a 30-second
question
thank you mr speaker the leader of the
opposition accused the minister of
returning from ukraine having made empty
promises and using empty words i'm
looking at a tweet from none other than
the defense minister of ukraine talking
about the centuries-old friendship
between canada and ukraine thanking her
and our minister of defense and the
prime minister for delivering on upping
the uh nuke the campaign on operation
unifier are you saying that he's using
empty words and engaging in twitter
diplomacy
now the honorable leader of the
opposition will respond in 30 seconds or
less i want to remind the honorable
members to speak through the chair not
directly across
the leader of the opposition
mr speaker it's rather ironic that a
liberal mp will stand up and criticize
my critique of using twitter for
diplomacy by quoting a tweet about
diplomacy mr speaker
what ukraine wants and we all know this
the minister knows this from the closed
door meetings in fact we also saw
the former ukrainian diplomat to canada
talking this weekend about the request
for many years now for lethal military
aid
our friends are in need
and while loan guarantees and a range of
other things are positive we have to
help ukraine now i ask the minister to
finding deliver on this military
equipment
[Applause]
emphasizes
slightly
uh
is
what three minutes
is
is
is
is
on the ground
[Music]
oh
germany what happened
again
[Music]
that's enough
simply recognizing
we have
i think
said that uh
is
[Music]
questions
um
russia as a member of nato we're
actively participating
within
nato
russia
finally
normandy foreign
when it comes to security
the president of france is speaking with
the president of russia putin and that
is why
[Music]
to talk about it and i had the
opportunity
[Music]
and i raised the issue of ukraine
and i said that i was very concerned
as soon as i mentioned my concern
the reaction
was
extremely strong
we will continue
potential invasions
is the fact
[Music]
speak questions
uh
foreign
and
[Music]
hello
foreign
[Music]
federation it was
in terms of foreign
part of an alliance
[Music]
to
who was in power at the time
or rather the influences
advisor who said that
thomas that was given by the western
powers
out to mikhail
as well mr speaker but thank you uh well
new democrats we support the the
non-combat military training we don't
support the provision of arms or lethal
military gear as my my colleague so
adequately and when and
put forward and i i noticed that the
member across the way reacted quite well
so if he could expand upon his thoughts
to the the pushing for conservative
members or from conservative members on
that provision of of lethal military
gear and what the the consequences of
that are thank you mr speaker
[Music]
um
debate the honourable member for burnaby
south
thank you very much mr speaker
i'll be sharing my time
with the honorable member for edmonton
strathcona
during this time my thoughts and on
behalf of all new democrats our thoughts
are with the ukrainian community in this
difficult time
the ukrainian community here in canada
and in ukraine and around the world are
not only grappling with a global
pandemic which is made
which has caused
incredible difficulties in people's
lives and in
immense sacrifice and hardship on top of
that people of ukraine now are worried
and deeply filled with anxiety and fear
about the threat of invasion
and in all of this i want to be very
clear new democrats
collectively we stand in full solidarity
with the people of ukraine
[Music]
and we know that this fear and this
worry and this anxiety is based on
legitimate threats
russia has already invaded ukraine
and at this very moment as we all know
illegally occupies both crimea and
donetsk
occupations which the new democrats
strongly denounce
the ongoing and active conflict in
eastern ukraine continues to cause a
heavy humanitarian toll for millions of
civilians
even before this last series of
escalation of tension
2.9 million people including over
400 000 children
required humanitarian assistance
children in eastern ukraine have grown
up
knowing conflict for the past eight
years enduring violence shelling and
being displaced from their homes
escalating hostilities could lead to
further mass displacement of refugee
crisis and an untold number of
casualties
humanitarian seriousness
consequences for millions of individuals
canada was the first country to
recognize ukraine's independence 30
years ago
we must continue to support
an independent and democratic ukraine
new democrats believe that canada should
continue to work with our allies to find
a real diplomatic solution to this
looming crisis
canada should force that should focus
its efforts on diplomacy
non-lethal assistance and economic
sanctions against russia including but
not limited to the magninsky sanctions
as a deterrent
bloodshed must be avoided through
coordinated international pressure and
stronger sanctions
weapons
is
that peace is achievable only through
diplomacy
new democrats urge the canadian
government to continue to do his part to
support the people of ukraine through
abrust through robust diplomacy
millions of eastern europeans are
counting on us to help foster peace
let's not disappoint them
merci
thank you thank you
questions and comments the honourable
member for utremo
thank you very much mr speaker and i was
pleased and relieved to hear the leader
of the ndp say that he stands in
solidarity with the ukraine
however the ndp member for winnipeg
south described the ukrainian government
as a quote
anti-semitic neo-nazi and fascist
militia the ndp member for churchill
kuwatnikasky
retweeted a suggestion that our deputy
prime minister
quote nazi past was the reason that
canada is supporting ukrainian
sovereignty will the leader of the ndp
denounce these inflammatory offensive
comments from his caucus members in this
house comments which i would say
resemble
very eerily russian propaganda
the honorable
member for burnaby south
the members in question have expressed
regret about those comments and i want
to be very clear that new democrats
stand in solidarity with ukraine we
absolutely
condemn the actions of russia we condemn
the already the legal occupations that
are ongoing and and as a further point i
think my own colleague is right to raise
concerns about the language
language that is thrown around that can
can incite uh that that strikes the core
of anti-semitism has no place in our
parliament and new democrats are
strongly
in
in solidarity with not just ukraine and
the ukrainian people but we are opposed
to
language that that is
use inappropriately um when when
throwing on words like the holocaust or
nazi they have real dire impacts uh and
they have dire impacts on the jewish
community and for that reason we are
very concerned about that type of
language when it's used inappropriately
questions and comments casey neistat the
honourable member for selkirk interlake
eastman well mr speaker um you know i
want to follow up on what was just asked
and the leader of the ndp just
apologized on behalf of of uh the
hateful comments that came from the
member of his caucus from winnipeg
center
and i just want to know is there going
to be a sanctioning of this member for
her
very callous
and hateful comments made about the
ukrainian
army as well as the people of ukraine
never mind the ukrainian canadians who
make up a large percentage of her own
riding in winnipeg center including the
headquarters of the united or the
ukrainian canadian congress who is in
winnipeg center so to have
one of his members get up and to
try to label those that are fighting for
their freedom today
as nazis
as calling them anti-semitic uh to me
that is as deplorable and i would ask
that the leader of the ndp
sanctioned that individual in his caucus
for burnaby south
i want to make it very clear that new
democrats stand in solidarity with the
people of ukraine i know there are so
many ukrainian canadians people that
come from ukraine that have deep ties
and deep connections and care deeply
about what's going on and they're seeing
their relatives and their friends right
now living under the fear and anxiety
and worry of a further invasion and the
escalating conflict has
borne a lot of pain already and
continues to apply a lot of pressure and
a lot of fear on ukrainian canadians as
well as ukrainians across the world and
of course in ukraine so i wanted i want
uh ukrainian canadians and
the ukrainian community at large to know
we stand in solidarity with you we
support an independent democratic
ukraine and we will continue to be
allies in pushing for a de-escalation
and a diplomatic solution to protect the
people of ukraine
questions and comments questions
the honourable member for edmonton
strathcona a 30-second question and
hopefully a 30-second answer
thank you remember for his for his
comments and for his support for the
ukrainian community um one of the
questions that i have for him
we've seen under the conservatives and
then the liberals a decimation of
international development a decimation
of our foreign um our foreign policy our
our role in the world canada's role in
the world can can he comment on what
could look what this could look like if
canada still had you know strong
peacekeeping strong diplomatic and
strong international development efforts
remember for burnaby south in 30 seconds
or less please
i really appreciate the question we've
seen that canada's role in the world has
been diminished consecutive conservative
and liberal governments have been
cutting our resources whether it's the
diplomatic core or our peacekeeping
roles if we had that role we could play
a greater
partnership in pushing for peace we
could play have a greater impact on the
global stage and that's something the
new democrats have continued to push for
increasing our peacekeeping increasing
our federal uh our diplomatic core so
that we can play that role in pushing
and promoting for peace
resuming debate reprised the honourable
member for edmonton strathcona
mr speaker and i again i would like to
thank um thank my leader the member from
burnaby south for his comments tonight
in support of of the ukrainian community
canada as many people have said before
tonight has a very special relationship
with ukraine canada was the first
country to recognize ukraine as an
independent sovereign country 30 years
ago
there are over
1.4 million canadians that identify as
being of ukrainian heritage in canada
and while ukrainians have chosen to
settle in country in communities across
canada
nowhere else has their impact been as
great as within the prairie provinces
provinces like my own home province of
alberta
ukrainians have been instrumental in
building our communities
our cities
our provinces and our country
edmonton has a strong
vibrant ukrainian community
recently i visited one of my dear
friends theodora gerasimio she is a
ukrainian artist she makes unbelievably
beautiful mosaics that celebrate the
pride and the history of the ukrainian
people in canada
and i'm very proud to say that the new
democratic party stands strongly in
solidarity with the people of ukraine
over the years my ndp colleagues have
called repeatedly for greater support
for ukraine through increased
development aid
for democratic and government support
for canada to extend visa free travel to
ukrainians and increase trade
relationships
like the 2016 canada ukraine free trade
agreement
my own predecessor many of you have
worked with linda duncan
was actually the awarded the executive
hetman award for her support of ukraine
and the ukrainian canadian community
mr speaker as the ndp foreign affairs
critic and the vice chair of the canada
ukraine friendship association
i will continue the work that has been
done by my ndp colleagues to strengthen
canada ukrainian relations
and it's that special relationship
that has me rising to speak in this
house today
at this moment in time
when ukrainian canadians are so worried
about their friends and family
when people in ukraine are increasingly
being threatened by an aggressive and
belligerent russia
canada must do more to work with our
allies we must work with the united
nations we must work with the ocse we
must work with nato to find real
diplomatic solutions to this looming
crisis
canada must not escalate and inflame an
already precarious situation
but rather focus our efforts on
diplomacy non-lethal assistance and
economic sanctions including magnitsky
sanctions to deter russia from
escalating this conflict
mr speaker i am worried about my friends
and i am worried about everyone in
ukraine
we cannot give putin a further excuse to
invade
we have to use every diplomatic tool we
have including sanctions to prevent a
devastating war that will cost lives
if russia further invades into ukrainian
territory ukrainians will pay the price
ukrainian civilians will be injured
displaced and killed children and women
in ukraine will bear the brunt of this
violence and those impacts will be felt
for decades or longer
u.n secretary general guiterrez has
urged the use of diplomacy stating that
there should not be any military
intervention but rather that diplomacy
is the way to solve the problems
and the under secretary general for
political and peacekeeping affairs
rosemary de carlo repeated that any
military invention intervention
involving russia or nato alliance forces
must be averted
canadian global affairs institute fellow
anderasias a defense expert and former
department of national defense official
has explicitly said that if canada sends
arms to ukraine it would aggravate the
situation
to quote you'd be neutralizing your
effect if you put arms in and then try
to negotiate you could do both there's
no law against it but you'd be
neutralizing your effect
there is still time mr speaker working
with our allies canada can de-escalate
this conflict we can use economic
sanctions we can include removal of
russia from the swift international
payment system and sanctions on russia's
sovereign debt how we respond to this
crisis how we use diplomacy and
sanctions to de-escalate this crisis
will be an indication of whether or not
canada is indeed back on the world stage
thank you mr speaker questions and
comments questions
the honorable member for winnipeg north
yes thank you uh mr speaker i want to
pick up on the
on the statement that canada does have a
very special and unique relationship
with ukraine
when something's happening in ukraine it
matters in canada
not only to the 1.4 million people of
canadian heritage
but to canadians as a whole
and that's why we need
to have the government engaged
the 120 million dollar loan
something that's badly needed and
warranted and supported by the
government
the need to that we have seen over the
years to train thirty thousand
personnel military personnel in ukraine
from entering into agreements like the
free trade agreement
to
give more hope to the people of ukraine
and here in canada
and i'm hoping that we'll hear more
tonight about that special relationship
and through that special relationship we
have an obligation
and i believe that the government needs
to continue to move forward
as we have
responsibly
thinking in terms of how it is we can
support the people of ukraine and i'm
wondering if my colleague could provide
her thoughts on that
edmonton strathcona thank you mr speaker
and i would like to thank my colleague
for for highlighting again just how
important that relationship is with
ukraine there are many things that we
can do right now we can work with
sanctions we should be in fact investing
more in our diplomatic core so that when
there are conflicts around the world
canada can take that place back that
we've that we've seen so diminished
under both the conservatives and and the
liberals that you know we don't have a
peacekeeping diplomatic core we are no
longer the convener of world peace we
are no longer who we should be and and
it's disappointing so so what i would
see is that canada invests in things
like international development in our
diplomatic core in peacekeepers you know
we had promises of peacekeepers going
out into the field that have not been
met not even close so there's so many
more things that we could do that would
help in situations like what we're
facing in ukraine but in future
situations because this is not the first
time and it is not the last time that a
bully is going to try to to invade and
impose their will on a on another
country questions and comments questions
the honourable member for calgary
shepherd thank you mr speaker so just
responding to some of the members
comments i don't know if i'll have a
question but just more commentary she
mentioned that you know compared the
russian federation and president putin
to a bully and of course we know that
bullies only respond to strength not to
more talking at this point more talking
without some type of action without a
response that strengthens ukraine's
capacity to defend itself is just going
to encourage president putin and the
military to keep preparing for war
they've been moving troops into belarus
on this fake
training exercise so they have this
longer undefended border that they can
invade through there are other countries
that have been already contributing uh
firearms and weapons to ukraine whether
it's turkey whether it's latvia estonia
poland have been providing arms to
ukraine because we know this they need
to defend themselves they need to means
to try and equalize the huge difference
in forces between an all-weather very
professional combat force in the russian
military and ukraine that is still
trying to pick itself out of fighting an
endless
war with russian separatists supported
by the russian federation more talk
isn't going to achieve this the bully
isn't going to go away the bully just
getting more arms more people more
weapons deliver a more crushing blow to
the ukrainian government
member for edmonton strathcona thank you
mr speaker and i i have to disagree with
my colleague across the across the way
uh
hitting a bully is not the best way to
deal with bullying i mean realistically
i have a 13 year old son i certainly
wouldn't want the member advising him
how to deal with bullying at his school
i think there are better ways for us to
do that there are more responsible ways
to do that and i would say that for
example if you are dealing with somebody
who is being aggressive and you punch
them in the nose it is not going to
de-escalate the situation it is not
going to turn down the the temperature
and to be perfectly fair i'm not going
to be in ukraine the member is not going
to be in ukraine there are women there
are children there are civilians that
are going to get caught in the middle of
this so so when he escalates this those
are the people that pay the price not
not him not me not anyone in this
chamber so we have an obligation to be
responsible we have an obligation to
seek a peaceful resolution
resuming debate reprised
the honourable member for etobicoke
center
thank you very much mr speaker and i'm
proud to rise as part of this emergency
take no debate on ukraine and the
build-up of russian forces along its
borders i'll be sharing my time with the
member for parkdale-high park
a week and a half ago i was joined by a
number of my colleagues in requesting
this emergency debate and we thought it
was important because it was we thought
it was important that members from all
parts of this country and from all
parties have a chance to discuss and
debate canada's and the international
community's response to this crisis that
is so important not only to the people
of ukraine but to our allies
and to canada
i'd like to thank members from all sides
of this house for supporting the motion
for this debate
just over 30 years ago ukraine declared
its independence and
one in ukraine declared its independence
i was watching the news coverage with my
grandfather yvonne
my grandfather was a great ukrainian
patriot and when he lived in ukraine
under the soviet union he risked his
lives on many occasions to try to defend
ukrainian culture and heritage and to
allow for enable ukraine's independence
when ukraine became independent we were
watching it on the news
and it was probably the proudest day of
his life
and i remember my grandfather saying and
i was about 14 years old at the time i
remember my grandfather saying
to me now that ukraine is independent we
have to keep working to defend its
independence
and i said to him
though i called him too i said what are
you talking about
ukraine just declared its independence
the people of ukraine wanted the
international communities recognized it
you're wrong the battle is over
you're wrong
i was wrong
in 2014 russia twice invaded ukraine
once in crimea and then illegally
annexed it and then in eastern ukraine
that war has raged to this very day and
14 000 ukrainians have died in that war
one and a half million people have been
displaced in 2014
the world did not do enough
it didn't do not it did not do
everything possible to deter invasion
and it did not do everything possible to
support ukraine
recently russia has amassed a hundred
thousand troops on ukraine's borders
along with significant military assets
this aggression is a major threat not
only to ukraine but to canada and to our
allies an invasion of ukraine would put
russian soldiers on nato's eastern
border just imagine the military and
diplomatic and financial resources
canadians and other countries will have
to invest to defend our nato allies from
a further invasion
it also puts canada under threat russia
is our neighbor to the north and russia
has tried to claim parts of the canadian
arctic for its own in the past if we
allow an invasion of ukraine i can only
message imagine the message that would
send to countries that wish to invade
their neighbors or change borders by
force i can only imagine the message
that would send to russia with regards
to the canadian arctic
that is why ukraine security is europe's
security it's the world security and
it's canada's security and that's why i
believe canada and its allies must do
everything possible to deter
an invasion of ukraine and to support
ukraine
over the past eight years this
government has done a tremendous amount
to support ukraine and you heard the
prime minister and the minister speak to
that last week the prime minister
announced a number of important
initiatives the expansion of unifier
humanitarian aid 120 million loan etc he
also announced that minister anand would
be traveling to ukraine she's there now
to understand what ukraine's needs are
she's our minister of defense
and that all options are on the table
so i hope
that we do everything possible
everything we can to deter an invasion
and to support ukraine
you know in 1991
that day with my grandfather i was wrong
in 2014
the world was wrong
we cannot afford to get this wrong again
there is too much at stake ukraine
security
is europe's security it's the world
security and it's canada security so
let's take stock of what's needed let's
take every step we can every step that's
possible and if we do this we will
succeed in deterring invasion and if we
do that we'll have much more to
celebrate
not for one year not for just another 30
years but for generations to come in
ukraine
and canada
and around the world
[Applause]
the honorable member for calgary uh
shepherd before he goes to his question
i just want to remind all the members
that again i realize it's kind of
relaxed and we're here
but when we're referring to someone
refer to him by their title not by their
name even
i know sometimes uh it slips away on us
i just want to remind everyone the
honourable member for calgary shepherd
thank you mr speaker i like to thank the
member for what i would term as you know
a strong endorsement of support for
ukraine and for ensuring its territorial
integrity which again
as someone of polish origins
many eastern europeans who fled to
canada over the last century because
usually came here different waves
usually look to eastern europe and it's
still a troubled region typically
because of the russian federation it's
in its different names that it's come in
the member talked about doing everything
possible and all the options are out
there i want to remind them that
countries like turkey lithuania estonia
latvia poland are sending arms to
ukraine i wonder if the member could
comment on that and whether the
government of canada will be doing as
well
the honourable member for atopical
center
thank you very much and i thank the
member opposite for for the question
like i said i think the
uh i think canada i think the
international community needs to do
everything possible
and i think uh minister you know as the
prime minister announced minister anand
is in ukraine to assess um the needs
ukraine's needs
uh what can be best done to deter
invasion i look forward to hearing what
minister anand has to say when she
returns
um but like i said i think it's
incumbent upon all of us the
international community to do everything
we can um because it's in not just
because it's ukraine interests but
because it's in canada's interest as
well
questions and comments questions
the honourable member for ottawa west
nepean
thank you very much mr speaker and i
want to thank my honorable colleague for
articulating so well
exactly what is at stake here we must
remain steadfast in supporting ukraine i
am very pleased to see that our
government is standing up to russian
aggression
that we are doing so with every tool
available with our diplomatic tools we
have seen both our foreign affairs
minister and our defense minister in
ukraine in recent days with sanctions
with over 400 sanctions on individuals
or entities with the sovereign loan of
120 million to ukraine and through our
presence there and it's been years of
support to ukraine through military
support through operation unifier and
operation reassurance i would like to
ask my colleague why it is so important
that we use every single tool at our
disposal to show our resolute support
for the people of ukraine thank you
member for etobicoke center
thank you very much and i'd like to
thank my colleague for her for her
question and for her support
um
i think it's important for for a number
of reasons first of all because i think
i think that when we look at
what could happen if russia invades
ukraine first of all russia will have
violated the sovereign
again
violated the sovereignty of its neighbor
ukraine this is not the first neighbor
sovereignty that russia will have
violated it invaded georgia in 2008.
and this is a threat to the world
international world-based order where we
respect each other's boundaries we
respect each other's borders and if this
is allowed to continue other countries
be it russia or others will see
will get the message that the
international community will tolerate
military powers invading their neighbors
and we cannot allow that that's a threat
to europe to our european allies and
it's a threat to canada and as i said
before russia has in the past tried to
lay claims to the canadian arctic i
think we have to give some serious
thought as canadians
to what would happen what kinds of
threats are opposed to us and to our our
allies in europe if russia is allowed to
do this
vladimir putin has in the past expressed
his desire to reconstitute the soviet
union under russia some of the eastern
european countries that my conservative
colleague spoke about
let's imagine a threat to them so this
is a threat to not only to ukraine but
to europe to europe and to canada and
that's why it's so important we take
every measure possible
questions and comments questions
we have time for a 30 second question 30
second answer the honourable member for
london fanshawe
you're
pushing it
mr speaker thank you um i wanted to ask
my colleague quickly um
uh of course in democrats we support
that extension of operation unifier but
we remain concerned that the reports of
extremism within the small parts of the
ukraine military
problems with our own military that we
have of course faced our armed forces
should not train or support any
far-right extremist groups so do you
agree that any canadian training must uh
assist the ukrainian military to become
more democratic more accountable and how
we're doing that currently
thank you mr speaker
the honourable member for etobicoke
center
i thank my colleague for the question i
think it's i think it's important that
we help the ukrainian military improve
in every way possible in fact that's
what i think operation unifier has been
doing if we look back at all of the
various elements of training that
operation unifier has provided it's not
just combat training it's it's
leadership it's integration it's
learning how countries with nato that
are part of nato how their militaries
operate that's so critical for ukraine
because
not only does strengthening ukraine's
military allow it to defend itself
against these russian invasions but it
increases the potential the probability
that ukraine will be able to enter nato
that cooperation that integration
amongst nato allies is one of the things
that makes this defensive alliance
possible so i think unifier is an
incredibly important mission i think it
plays an incredibly important role in
the short term and also in the long term
resuming debate
the honorable parliamentary secretary to
the minister of international trade
export promotion small business and
economic development thank you very much
mr speaker just today on january 31st
here in ottawa i just want to reference
something at the start of my comments i
agree fundamentally on the importance of
protest and free expression in any
democracy but i also agree that we must
all denounce hatred and vilification
things like wavings of swastikas and
confederate flags are jarring at all
times particularly on the fifth
anniversary of the quebec mass shooting
in days after international holocaust
remembrance day equally jarring is
seeing people dance on the tomb of the
unknown soldier the national war
memorial is dedicated to those veterans
who paid the ultimate sacrifice to give
us the freedom to do things like protest
those veterans deserve our respect
because they died fighting
authoritarianism this brings me to
authoritarianism right now mr speaker
what we're witnessing in eastern europe
and that of vladimir putin let's make no
mistake the aggressor in this context is
russia it is russia who invaded and
annexed crimea illegally it is russia
who invaded donbass eight years ago and
it is russia who now is the aggressor
amassing troops a hundred thousand
troops on ukraine's eastern
and northern borders
our support of ukraine is steadfast that
is not a partisan issue thankfully in
this chamber it is based on our long and
steadfast history in recent years it has
meant things like operation unifier
things like operation reassurance it has
meant signific
sanctions under magnitsky legislation it
has meant things like the canada ukraine
free trade agreement in the last several
weeks literally in the last 14 days mr
speaker that
bond has ramped up and what have we done
what actions concrete actions have been
taken because this has been put into
some debate on the part of the official
opposition we have sent hmcs montreal to
the mediterranean as part of operation
reassurance that left halifax two weeks
ago we've had the minister of foreign
affairs in kiev the minister of defense
is in kiev as i speak mr speaker we have
sent 50 million dollars in humanitarian
assistance something that the ndp has
injected into this debate rightfully
about assisting on the ground that is
being done with canadian federal dollars
we've provided sovereign loans to the
tune of 120 million dollars something
emphasized by the minister of foreign
affairs we've not just renewed operation
unifier we've expanded operation unifier
we're providing military equipment we're
also addressing something that is brand
new which didn't exist at the time that
the official opposition was in
government things like cyber threats and
addressing cyber threats using canadian
know-how to team up with ukrainian
know-how to better assist in that
particular aspect of the fight we've
launched a renegotiation of the canada
ukraine ukraine free trade agreement i
was happy to participate in that launch
with the minister of international trade
why does this matter mr speaker it
matters because as you've heard from my
colleague from etobicoke center the
security of ukraine is the security of
europe the security of the world and
ergo canada security and it matters to
canadians we've heard the member
opposite uh from calgary uh to talk
about his own polish background we know
that i represent for example polish
canadians and ukrainian canadians for
any person in this country who is either
from eastern europe or has ancestry in
eastern europe they know what russian
aggression looked like under the soviet
union and they're seeing it again now
and it is causing them considerable
anxiety anxiety to which we must respond
as a nation-state what is at stake mr
speaker it is the sovereign ability of
any nation to determine on its own about
its security arrangements and make
independent decisions about how to
protect its citizens and to those who
say canada is a small player and the
actions it takes will be inconsequential
i say you were dead fast you were dead
wrong you were dead wrong because canada
can lead and has led how have we led
when we deliver 120 million dollars in
sovereign loans the eu then follows with
additional money in sovereign loans
because they see canada leading by
example you've heard jen stoltenberg the
secretary general of nato reference that
leadership of canada that is what we
need more of mr speaker that is why we
called i called together the member of
etobicoke center and six of my
colleagues for this debate this evening
and what i pledge in this chamber right
now on behalf of my constituents on
behalf of the canadian people is that we
need to continue to do more and what
more can be done mr speaker two things
more can be done we can address economic
sanctions as a package we can address
economic sanctions now we need to
demonstrate to a person like putin that
the cost of potentially going to war is
far more expensive than the cost of
peace and lastly we must address
ukraine's defense where it is needed and
where we can provide assistance to
defending ukraine we must do so
including things such as providing
electronic jamming equipment which i
understand the the ukrainian minister of
defense has recently put in a request
for those are the types of things that i
will advocate for in this chamber i will
advocate for with my government and i
will advocate for on behalf of ukrainian
canadians whom i represent
mr speaker thank you
hey
good questions and comments the
honourable member for calgary shepherd
thank you mr speaker so i want to thank
the member for what i also think is a
speech and strong support of the writer
ukraine to its self-determination and
its borders as well as i've asked the
other member before you know i mentioned
there's a series of countries that have
actually offered already transferred uh
weapons and arms to ukraine in an effort
to try and bolster their military forces
in order to act as a deterrent to the
russian federation potentially invading
through into different parts of ukraine
and prolonging the war that they've been
fighting with them for several years
right now
will the member perhaps you know
explain the government canada's delays
in
sending arms as well from canada to
ukraine in support of our allies there
to ensure they can defend themselves
against russian aggression thank you
secretary
dominis
thank you thank you for to the member
from calgary shepherd and i would
actually take issue with just a certain
characterization characterization that
he made that the government of canada
has been delaying the fact that i was
able to list about five different
initiatives we've taken in a 14 day span
i think is the antithesis of delay i
think we have taken direct action and
most notably what i would say to him is
that the issue of providing assistance
to defend ukraine is a live one it is
one where all options are on the table
that's the first point the second point
is that we have to consider what
canada's been able to do thus far since
operation unifier was launched we've
provided training to no less than 33 000
ukrainian soldiers that is an
unbelievable amount that is a
significant impact for middle power in
terms of providing security and
assistance in terms of the sovereignty
and defense of ukraine i've been there
myself to observe those troops during
the celebrations for independence on the
maidan in 2018 i've seen what canadians
are doing i've seen what ukrainian
canadian soldiers are doing on the
ground it is needed it is wanted and it
is respected and that's more of the type
of contribution that we need to see
remember
oh
is
germany is reliant upon nordstrom 2 as a
source of energy this is causing some
division among western nations we know
the european parliament we know areas
like poland latvia lithuania and estonia
are against nordstrom 2. if that kind of
project goes ahead it poses some
instability within the western alliance
it is that kind of diplomacy that we
need to unify the western alliance so
that we can approach projects like
nordstrom 2
in a unified manner and approach
combating russian aggression in a
unified manner yes it will cool
questions and comments the honourable
member for london fan shop
um thank you mr speaker i uh i have
quite a a a strong community in in
london um from the diaspora the
ukrainian uh folks there uh and and dari
the president of the london chapter of
the ukrainian canadian congress
brought to me her concerns directly
and i was wondering considering he has
such a diverse community
that i would like to hear maybe
some of the
concerns from his
community directly on how they're
responding to to what's ultimately going
on and the government's response to that
thank you mr speaker
the honorable parliamentary secretary
thank you and i thank the member from
london fanshawe for a question and what
i'm hearing from constituents of my
community community is the anxiety in
fear and concerns about action and
wanting as much action as possible as
quickly as possible and i'm hearing from
the the ukrainian canadian congress the
president of the congress lives in my
riding for example what i'm also hearing
is that when people misconstrue what is
actually being provided misconstrue the
situation among the ukrainian armed
forces it doesn't help matters much i'm
going to return to a comment that was
raised earlier about the member from
winnipeg south in the very volatile
comments that she made which
unfortunately still exist on twitter as
i speak so yes an apology has been made
by the leader of the ndp but the fact
that those tweets remain on the record
for the member from winnipeg south is
not constructive to the conversation or
the support of ukraine
representing debate the honorable number
for selkirk interlake eastman well thank
you mr speaker i'll be spending my time
with the member from renfrew nipissing
pembroke uh and i just want to make sure
i correct the
the the
members from parkdale high who just
spoken just so it was the member from
winnipeg center that made that tweet not
the member from winnipeg's house who was
a colleague of his and i know it would
be
unfair to him to associate him with
those uh ridiculous and hurtful comments
by the member of winnipeg center
mr speaker i know that all of us here
first and foremost stand in unity with
ukraine and i know that we all stand
here to denounce
the aggressive escalation of actions
taken by vladimir putin and the russian
federation we all
know that putin is provoked by weakness
and
that's why it's so important that we all
come together and stand in unison to
denounce how the russian federation has
tried to force nato's hand as using
ukraine as a bargaining ship in
in all this prepared to invade again
ukrainian sovereign territory on top of
the illegally occupied lands that
they're in and on bass and crimea which
we'll always see especially us on the
conservative benches will always see
those territories as ukrainian sovereign
lands
and never acknowledge that they are
russian even though they have their
forces holding gun point to the citizens
and crimea and on bass
vladimir putin
has
played this game before and
it just is coincidental it always seems
to happen around the time that there's a
winter olympics whether it was the
invasion of crimea after the sochi
olympics and before that it was in in
georgia uh and grabbing no sierra you
know it it it it seems to be the
olympics me there's a trigger for
vladimir putin to invade a neighbor and
you know ukraine has done nothing
but tried to get along with the russian
bear to the north they have
wanted to to definitely
see more integration with the european
union with nato and their western allies
and for those of us that are of
ukrainian heritage and i'm proud of our
ukraine heritage we have always stood up
for ukraine and luckily i am an elected
member as many many members here are and
i can stand and denounce vladimir putin
his kleptocrats and the kremlin for this
disgusting display they're putting on
right now with over 140 000 troops
sitting along uh ukraine's border uh and
and we're talking that they got troops
in belarus they got troops across
northern uh ukraine uh right around
heart keith down to the dunbas rust
stuff on dawn their navy sailing in the
sea of the zov and sailing of course in
the black sea and you know over 30 000
troops sitting in crimea today
all of that
is just saber-rattling but we could see
a greater escalation now you know as a
conservative and as ukrainian i'm proud
that it was as
very well articulated by our leader of
the opposition that you know it was
conservative governments that recognized
ukraine's sovereignty back in 1991 it
was a ukrainian or canadian government
under stephen harper that started
operation fire that provided uh the the
first uh
um defensive weapons for ukraine that
worked with them in reform and trying to
de-escalate the situation because we
understood
that a strong ukraine
will be a deterrent to an invading
russia
nato gets that and that's why nato has
always kept the door open to have the uh
open door policy with ukraine as
potential members and for russia to come
forward now with ridiculous demands
about trying to increase their sphere of
security trying to get nato to withdraw
troops from
neighboring nations that are already
nato members and to say that ukraine can
never get there
but we know mr speaker that we have to
do more we have to use meninski
sanctions and other economic sanctions
to deter russia now not after they
invade we know ukraine wants lethal
weapons the former ambassador of ukraine
to canada um
savchenko andre savchenko also said we
need to have lethal weapons we need to
restore the radar sad images that the
liberals canceled in 2016.
and you know we do thank the liberals
for what they did in expanding operation
unifier something we've been calling for
since 2019 and 2021 but there's more
that needs to be done the half measures
that have been taken so far from by by
this government has not deterred
vladimir putin all it has done is
appeased him
question a come on tower the honorable
member for kingston and the islands
thank you very much uh mr speaker and i
want to thank the member from selkirk
into lake eastman for his intervention
today he certainly um knows a great deal
about this topic and i've always
respected to um everything he's had to
say and i've indeed learned a lot from
him on this file we used to sit on uh
the defense committee together at least
i used to be there i imagine he still is
and we had the opportunity to travel to
ukraine uh a number of years ago um and
one of the things that i felt so um
inspired by as a canadian was that when
we were there we heard stories i
remember the member and i sat with uh
with amongst other people
the chair of the defense committee of
ukraine who told us
other countries
were coming to support ukraine because
canada was there canada played this
incredible leadership role in being able
to
mobilize and encourage other countries
to get involved and to be part of that
uh you you you uh presence in ukraine
can the member uh comment as to you know
his thoughts on how canada's role goes
beyond at times just monetary
and other asset resources the honourable
member for selkirk interlake eastman
speaker i thank the colleague for for
the question and you know that was a a
great trip to actually go over there and
see uh how our military was working with
and training uh the ukrainian armed
forces in the ukrainian national guard i
want to thank all those members of the
canadian armed forces over the past uh
eight years that have been going back
and forth to ukraine
and working with them by training
ukrainian troops we have made them not
just better soldiers we have helped save
lives and we know that more of that
needs to be done but that's why we
started calling back in 2018 for a long
term expansion and extension of
operation unifier and we also have been
calling for since 2018 as conservatives
to provide lethal defensive weapons
because ukraine has asked for them our
other allies have provided them why
isn't canada
questions and comments the honourable
member for edmonton strathcona
i also would like to thank the member
for his for his comments i've worked
with him in the in the canada ukraine
friendship group and and he is extremely
knowledgeable about this topic and and i
as well have learned a great deal from
him um
earlier
earlier in the year we were we were on a
on a television interview together and
and he he brought something up and it
it's been sitting with me for a very
long time and and as i as i listen to
conservatives talk about how we need to
escalate how we need lethal weapons how
we need to to amp up this this war talk
my my thoughts go back to when he said
that the conservative government would
cede not one inch and i just want to
know
how did that work out in 2014 because
you know what that was the government of
the conservatives and it was more than
an inch and i'm wondering why he thinks
that the conservative government that
was not able to prevent the invasion of
ukraine in 2014 will be able to prevent
the invasion with the exact same
rhetoric in 2022.
the honourable member for selkirk
interlake eastman
our rhetoric mr speaker needs to be
strong it's one thing that vladimir
putin understands
and there's only one person that's
talking about war in ukraine and that's
vladimir putin
what we're talking about and what the
ukrainian canadian community is talking
about and what the people of ukraine are
asking for
is the ability to defend themselves they
are prepared to go and do the street
fighting if russian soldiers march over
the border again and try to grab more
ukrainian territory
and we want to make sure they have the
ability to do that to protect their
homeland to protect their families to
protect their communities and to not
provide those lethal defensive weapons
with only providing you know empty
rhetoric
we have failed them
and it's time for us to stand up and do
the right thing and stand with our
friends families and ally in
ukraine you know a come ontario very
short one the honorable member for
etobicoke
i'm looking at the wrong side but uh
there you go the etobicoke center
thanks very much speaker and
i'd like to thank the member for his for
his intervention and and um i have the
opportunity to work with him closely
i've been on defense committee with him
but also on the candidate crane
parliamentary friendship group
um
i
i was a little bit surprised at one
moment during his speech when he talked
about how
the conservative government sent lethal
weapons to ukraine
the conservative government didn't send
lethal weapons to ukraine
so i do i do think it's interesting that
he spoke to that here and is advocating
for that here suggested it's been done
in the past when it hasn't been done in
the past and in 2014 the world didn't do
enough my question to him though is
could he speak to as someone who's been
on the defense committee and knows the
armed forces so well the importance of
training the ukraine armed forces and
the impact that that's having uh for the
ukrainian armed forces as they take the
fight or to defend themselves against
the russian invasion
pretty second answer the honourable
member for selkirk intellege eastman i
said we've provided defensive weapons
and and just to be clear on it was that
canada actually approved export permits
from a canadian company selling sniper
rifles to ukraine and we helped
facilitate that so that the ukraine and
army could actually come here and buy
sniper rifles like high-quality canadian
sniper rifles to defend their territory
so we made sure that those approvals and
permits were put in place
we can't even get that from this
government today and so i just say this
let's get off our our duffs and let's do
the right thing let's step up before
putin marches across the border and
provide the people of ukraine with all
the tools whether it's sanctions whether
it's weapons whether it's intelligence
whether it's financing but give them all
the tools so they can defend their own
territory
continuing today the honourable member
for renfrew nipissing
pembroke mr speaker as a conservative
member parliament for rent for nipissing
pembroke i'm proud to recognize the
contributions that canadians with
ukrainian heritage have made to canada
canadians like former governor general
reinetition and the honourable michael
star the first canadian cabinet minister
of ukrainian descent he was a member of
the government of the right honourable
john diefenbaker who gave canadians the
bill of rights
it bears repeating that canada enjoys a
special relationship with ukraine almost
1.4 million canadians can claim
membership in the ukrainian diaspora the
largest outside ukraine and russia it's
ironic that this debate is taking place
while average canadians have started a
popular movement the freedom convoy to
gain back freedoms canadians enjoyed
prior to the liberal party lockdown
mandate it's ironic because the roots of
the current crisis in ukraine date back
several years to the popular uprising
that took place in ukraine's capital of
kiev
the ukrainian revolution of the maidan
was the outpouring of people longing for
freedom democracy and rule of law the
dream of a better future
the same thing our truckers want for all
canadians
canadians cheered the orange revolution
and cheered again the revolution of the
maidan
canada was the first western nation to
recognize ukraine's independence after
the fall of the soviet union
ukraine citizens look to the west to
realize their dreams
they're still looking for canada
at first the revolution of the maidan
was met with brutal violence and
aggression the pro-russian government of
victor yanukovych used the same kind of
language to describe ukrainian
protesters as canadians are hearing from
the prime minister and certain members
of his ruling clique described the
freedom convoy
this eventually led to the pro-russian
oligarch victor yanukovych who had been
president of ukraine to abducate going
into hiding fleeing the country
it was during this time of turmoil and
chaos that russian president vladimir
putin sees the southern ukrainian region
of crimea
next came the taking of the eastern
ukrainian regions of donetsk and luhansk
historians make the reference to the
events that preceded world war ii and
the seizing of territories from adjacent
countries by nazi germany using the same
excuses as the russian president is
making to seize ukrainian territory
compounding today's crisis
america suffers from a domestically
unpopular president whose policies have
divided america
power [ __ ] a vacuum
there's no shortage of nations who are
ready to exploit american weakness like
china and russia
and that leads to the situation the
world finds itself in today
since 2014 in the russian seizure of
crimea almost 14 000 people have lost
their lives many children have been
maimed by land mines there are a million
and a half displaced persons
now is the time for diplomacy
and diplomatic language
lives are in the balance
what was the prime minister thinking
when he signaled the state broadcaster
cbc to float a wacky russian conspiracy
theory was he trying to discredit the
canadian freedom protesters with his
clumsy attempt at disinformation
it failed
once again the prime minister is the
object of scorn and derision not just
among canadians but around the world
all the world is watching canadians and
the protest outside so far the russian
media has been content to ridicule the
leader of the liberal party
the people of ukraine do not need the
prime minister saying or doing something
foolish we know from the experience of
world war one how quickly a seemingly
minor unrelated action can trigger a
chain of events too horrible to think of
there's no denying that we live in a
disturbingly anxious and contentious
times
apocalyptic assertions of climate change
by the environment
ignorant tirades
public shaming tactics and crude weapons
of moral accusation by the prime
minister have increasingly taken place
the place of rational discourse
even before
the shamefulness of the afghanistan
debacle
there's been a disgust with the
self-serving incompetence of this
government and its lack of a coherent
foreign policy
the time for half measures has long
passed ukraine needs canada's support
the prime minister and his deputy have
let them down
questions and comments questions
are the honorable member for kingston in
the islands notwithstanding i had a very
difficult time following the logic there
and i'm sure if we'd given her another
five minutes maybe we would have had
this connected back to area 51 and
aliens mr speaker but my question for
the member is
my question for the member uh mr speaker
is she was in ukraine with me
together
about three years ago when we were on
the defense committee together and she
heard ukrainians the the the
chair of the defense committee in
ukraine talk about the incredible
contribution that canada makes to
operation unifier and operations
reassurance can she somehow
justify for me why it is that she has
such a a different view of it from the
realities of what we actually heard
together when we were there
well member for renfrew nipissing
pembroke so uh mr speaker um i do know
that uh i recall when we first decided
to do operation reassurance and
operation unifier
and how the people
were very happy in fact we even were
instrumental in setting up the center of
excellence stratcom and latvia for the
misinformation that was
uh being perpetuated by the russians but
i'm afraid to say uh the member
opposites memory isn't quite that great
although i would have loved to have been
in ukraine with the defense committee at
that time i was unable to so um i was
with you there in spirit uh mr speaker
but uh i hope to be there one day in the
future when they they are enjoying peace
throughout the land
question
i'll get it in a second moose jaw lake
center lane again
thank you mr speaker i uh
want to start this off by uh feeling
like i'm back in university i i spent a
number of years at king's college
university of
london in england studying war studies
and
the history of ukraine
and the history of russia and the
geopolitics in this
is is a
very long history
and we have to recognize the ukrainian
people in their sacrifice during world
war ii
to liberate
us from potential nazi oppression over 8
million people sacrificed their lives
they were sacrificed by
a nation russia that didn't really care
for them
and so i would ask my colleague if she
would agree with me because i'm afraid
that the narrative has been taken away
and and been put on russia where they're
trying to defend themselves you don't
defend yourselves by expanding your
borders and and using another nation as
a pun would you agree with that member
for renfrew nipissing pembroke first
first of all mr speaker i'd like to
thank my honorable colleague for his
service and the canadian military and
his
academics on this subject
uh yes i do agree with the
my colleague and uh
i have nothing but courage and
look to the actions of the ukrainian
people and their indomitable spirit to
go ahead and
create a land and live in a land that is
free
question come ontario questions and
comments the honourable member etobicoke
center
thanks very much mr speaker and
and um i was listening intently to the
to the members uh remarks and i think a
lot of members during this debate have
spoken about the need to
deter
russia's further invasion of ukraine
and i'm wondering if the member could
speak to the steps that she believes uh
canada and the international community
need to take to deter a further invasion
of ukraine
i remember her renfrew nipissing
pembroke
thank you mr speaker i i think that we
continue showing our support uh training
uh the troops there making sure that one
of the things we could do is provide
them with the radar set imagery so
they could see more clearly
what is forming
in front of them and protect themselves
more
fully
questions and comments any last one
before we move on
sure the honorable member for tobacco
center
thank you
and i'm just following up on that
question uh when we
one of the things that um
one of the things that's changed so much
since 2014 for the ukrainian military is
its capabilities
and much of that capability has been
developed through the support of
its partner countries like canada
through unifier but like the united
states the uk and others who have
training missions i wonder if the member
could speak to
um whether she believes this aspect has
been important in helping the ukrainians
strengthen their position in defense of
their country and whether this is an
important aspect of deterrence as well
renfrew nipissing pembroke very short
answer mr speaker the ukrainian people
are facing uh and a military from
land sea and air
on land alone of upwards of a hundred
and thirty thousand troops
their numbers are far smaller uh and i'm
confident that uh what that we have done
uh in the past is uh
is helping them greatly but
2014 came
as a total surprise in fact at nate i
was at a nato meeting at that time and
they were all enjoying the peace
dividend this is that was a warning at
the night during that night little green
men came across the border and everybody
was shocked so now we're
we shouldn't be shocked when it happens
if it happens we still pray that uh
calmer minds will prevail but we are
with the people no matter what
continuing debate the honorable minister
of international development and
minister responsible for the pacific
economic development agency of canada
mr speaker before i continue i'd like to
indicate that i will split my time with
the honourable minister of tourism
mr speaker it is essential that we
continue to support ukraine in the days
ahead
that we remember that we are not only
supporting a nation
we are supporting its people
people who are living with the
uncertainty
uncertainty of a potential invasion
people who continue to struggle to build
their democracy in the shadow of russian
threats
and those people who continue to be
affected by the
humanitarian impact of the ongoing
conflict in eastern europe
and canada has been a consistent
consistent supporter of the humanitarian
response in ukraine since
our humanitarian assistance provides
support to the people most affected by
this crisis including those in
non-government controlled areas in the e
restrictions have separated the
population from the rest of ukraine
many of whom
who are who are
underemployed or elderly and find
themselves cut off from the social
services such as health care and their
pensions
through our experienced humanitarian
partners including the united nations
agency
communities and the international
committee of the red cross ken has
sought to address the basic needs of
ukrainian
people to protect civilians living near
the contact line and to respond to
increased needs due to covenant 19
and since 2014 canada has provided over
49.5 million
in in humanitarian assistance funding uh
to the ukrainian people making us the
fourth largest single country donor of
humanitarian assistance funding to
ukraine
now this funding is having a real impact
on the ground in 2020 we helped support
69 health centers provided water and
shelter assistance to over 1.4 million
people
increased food consumption for over 220
000 people and boosted food production
for over 32 000 people
and we are prepared to do more and last
week our government announced that we
will provide 15 million dollars in
new humanitarian assistance to support
humanitarian partners to respond with
the flexibility a situation in ukraine
that you that ukraine requires
our assistance will focus on priorities
that matter to the people on the ground
ensuring people's access to basic
services to health water and sanitation
shelter and food security
the increased assistance will also
strengthen
protection including for the almost one
million individuals remain internally
displaced
we will provide advocacy and support for
freedom of movement for the families
that remain separated by the contact
line in many cases unable to even
communicate with family members cut off
from them because of the conflict
our support for the immediate
humanitarian needs of those affected by
the conflict in ukraine is complementary
to other long-term development and
security support that is also supporting
ukraine's resilience in the face of
continued escalation of russian
aggression
and since 2014 in addition to our
support of humanitarian assistance
canada has provided over 250 million in
bilateral development assistance to
support ukraine to advance democracy
rule of law gender equality and the
empowerment of women and girls and
sustainable economic growth through this
development assistance we have supported
rural women entrepreneurs to improve
their agricultural production
agri
business financial management generating
economic opportunities for the most
vulnerable people living in rural
conflict-affected areas
we have fostered a vibrant and diverse
civil society landscape in ukraine that
can play a vital role in building
functioning democracies upholding the
rule of law access to justice and
promoting and protecting human rights we
have ensured that women's voices are
heard by helping local women's
organizations and networks to promote
women's rights advancing
now in the face of this aggression
canada is an increasing development
assistant by up to up to an additional
35 million dollars the support will fund
strategic peace and security initiatives
that respond to the evolving needs on
the ground these initiatives will work
to strengthen community resilience and
mitigate the drivers and impact of
instability our increased development
assistance will also help improve the
crisis management and emergency response
capacity in ukraine
it will also
allow some of our
department partners on the ground to
scale up programming to help ukraine
respond to the evolving needs of its
citizens and ensure it has the capacity
to continue to deliver services and
provide help to people if the situation
deteriorates even further it will also
enhance our support to civil society
including independent media and human
rights activists
our development aid of course does not
exist in isolation but in part of a
consolidated canadian effort to help the
government of ukraine build its economic
capacity
our offer of a sovereign loan of up to
120 million announced on january 21st
will also help the ukrainian government
um reinforce its economic resilience
so mr speaker it remains canada's hope
that the situation in ukraine does not
deteriorate but this depends on russia
we will continue to seek a diplomatic
resolution with our allies and partners
we will continue to call on russia to
de-escalate and to engage in a
meaningful dialogue in good debate we'll
also we will
do so not only because it is the best in
in the best interests of the people of
ukraine but also because all the only
viable path forward for russia
whatever comes canada will stand
alongside the people of ukraine our
humanitarian development support will be
there to help them meet their daily
needs and to help them as they fight for
an independent future
casting a commentary questions and
comments you'll remember calgary
shepherd thank you mr speaker i'd like
to thank the minister for uh i guess
taking part in this debate and kind of
explaining canada's humanitarian help
too
to ukrainians i talk about civic
institutions how important it is to
build them in ukraine one of the things
he mentioned is media how and we know
there's a large disinformation campaign
being run by the kremlin through
different outlets and you know closer to
home we have one of these outlets
operating right here in canada it's
called russia today it is a 24 hour pro
putin pro kremlin pro you know whatever
the the russian government thinks uh it
wants to spew into our airways it gets
carrier rights so while we're also
helping overseas to try and limit the
damage that these disinformation
campaigns can cause to sap the morale
and the strength of civic society to
resist in these types of situations i
wonder if the minister would agree that
russia today doesn't belong on canadian
airways either
the honourable minister of international
development
mr speaker we have been concerned about
russia's hybrid warfare tactics and the
methods that they have been using when
it comes to
misinformation um the cyber attacks
occur
and especially disinformation that comes
within canada this is why you've also
offered up support from our
communication security establishment
provide cyber support in these cases
thank you
a commander the honourable member for
edmonton strathcona
thank you mr speaker and i would like to
thank the minister for for his
intervention this evening and for
providing some clarity for us on
canada's intentions with regards to
international development um
i i would be amiss though if i didn't
raise the fact that right now uh canada
is is giving a very low amount of
overseas development assistance we are
at
0.31 percent of gni uh much lower than
we should be at much lower than the
government has repeatedly promised to
get to and and well what we're seeing in
ukraine right now um is happening is is
is an urgent urgent need i think what we
can be very clear on is that there is
going to be more conflict around the
world and that the best way we can deal
with conflict is to prevent it from
happening international development
plays a key role in that will canada
commit will the minister commit on
behalf of the government of canada to
increase our overseas development
assistance to be able to fully implement
the feminist international assistance
policy
honorable minister of international
development
mr speaker i agree with the honourable
member that it is very important for all
of us to to work towards preventing
conflict this is why our government has
increased our international development
funding and the speech from the prone
throne has also mentioned uh this i look
forward to working with the member to
look at other conflicts but in
particular in ukraine we have stepped up
and we will
look at other opportunities as a
situation changes thank you
questions and comments the honourable
member from altar video
michelle president
[Music]
is
um
uh
i thank the member for um the very
important question
um our government's uh response is a
comprehensive uh one i've had the
opportunity to visit ukraine on many
occasions i'm very proud of the time
that i had there had the opportunity to
attend president zielinski's
inauguration and in fact i actually took
my daughter to an event uh in toronto
where uh the president uh spoke because
this is an all-canadian effort and so
yes we are very proud of the work that
we're doing with operation uniform very
proud of the work when it comes to
trade but we're also the development
support is so needed right now and we
will continue to evolve our support as
the situation changes thank you
continuing debate the honorable minister
of tourism
well thank you very much mr speaker and
i appreciate the opportunity to join in
this uh important take note debate this
evening
this debate comes at a a moment of deep
anxiety for people across the country
uh it's ukrainian canadians across the
country fear for their friends and their
family back in ukraine as an mp from
edmonton i've spent my whole life
surrounded by
the beauty of ukrainian culture growing
up with ukrainian speakers ukrainian
friends
mr speaker and it's an essential part of
the tapestry of our community and at
this time it's crucial that we stand
with them uh with our ukrainian friends
and with the entire diaspora around the
world but i think it's important for us
to make it very clear
that the situation itself is clear and
stark that russia is the aggressor and
ukraine is the victim russia's military
buildup recently
announced joint military exercises with
belarus
hybrid attacks on ukrainian government
websites
propaganda and disinformation campaigns
and its weaponization of energy
represent a direct threat to the
ukrainian people
there's this is also occurring against a
backdrop of russia's ongoing aggression
against ukraine including its attempted
uh annexation illegal occupation of
crimea in 2014 its support for military
formations in eastern ukraine and human
rights violations
responsible current crisis
preparing
and our partners have engaged in intense
diplomacy amongst along several tracks
including at the nata russia council uh
self-determination
north atlantic council meeting on
january 17th we offered russia three new
meetings to discuss nato russia
relations uh the security situation in
europe as well as risk reduction
transparency arms control disarmament
and non-proliferation
russia has yet to accept any of these
meetings mr speaker
um
the minister of foreign
the minister underscored canada's
steadfast commitment to ukraine's
sovereignty territorial integrity and
independence
we've always been clear mr speaker
there's only one way forward and that is
for russia to de-escalate
it is russia that invaded georgia in
2008
and it is russia that violates
international law every day as it
continues to occupy parts of ukraine's
territory
canada is taking action
and has offered ukraine a sovereign loan
of 120 million dollars
as of january 21st in response to
president zielinski's request for
additional support
this loan will reinforce ukraine's
domestic stability and support the
country's economic resilience and
governance reforms a secure peaceful and
prosperous ukraine strengthens our
shared transatlantic security which
canada has a vested interest in
promoting and protecting
in this work mr speaker i want to
underscore the importance of unity and
coordination with our partners on firm
and severe response measures canada has
also been working closely with many
like-minded countries
to develop a set of robust and concrete
punitive measures chief among them
economic sanitations
we are prepared to meet further russian
military action with immediate and
hard-hitting sanctions that target
influential individuals and entities
linked to key sectors of the russian
economy mr speaker all options are on
the table
our engagement was further reinforced by
the announcement of the extension and
expansion of operation unifier to
provide enhanced military training and
mentorship to ukraine's security forces
through the end of march 2025.
canada will continue to work with our
allies and partners including the g7 the
eu nato the oesc the osce and the un
along with the international community
writ large to coordinate our responses
and continue to push russia to come to
the table for dialogue or face severe
consequences and costs
but it is ultimately russia's choice to
de-escalate the crisis and we are ready
to meet russia on either path
we urge russia to adhere to its
international commitments including
those under the osce helsinki act the
osce vienna document and the minsk
agreement for a peaceful resolution to
the conflict in eastern ukraine canada
will be steadfast in our support for
ukraine sovereignty territorial
integrity and self-determination
jacqui you mr president mr speaker
a commentary questions and comments the
honourable member for moose jaw lake
center flanigan
thank you mr speaker i the question that
i have is is what's this government's
priority is it the self-determination
of uh people like ukra in ukraine pardon
me
or
allowing for aggression and bullying
from russia
will administer tourism
mr speaker i think the um stakes are
very stark in this conflict and i think
it's
pretty clear to us on the government
side that this is a
battle against of of authority
authoritarianism uh versus democracy and
uh i know personally mr speaker that i
think this is
the biggest test for western democracies
in my lifetime and we need to stand
together with our
partners in western and eastern europe
against russian aggression and the world
is watching
and we need to get this right and we are
steadfastly committed to a peaceful
de-escalated resolution
to the situation and we must not stand
for increased russian aggression
in ukraine
questions and comments questions
the honorable member for london fan shop
thank you mr speaker new democrats have
called for many of uh and support many
of the actions that are being taken by
the government uh one of the things that
we've called for is the use of magnetsky
sanctions uh this hasn't been used by
the government since 2018. uh it's a
clear and strong tool that canada could
use against human rights violators and i
just wanted to know uh from this member
uh why it is that the government isn't
uh going forward with this reaction
thank you mr speaker
hello minister of tourism
well thank you very much mr speaker i
thank the honourable members uh support
and and very important question and i
think if we if we take a look back at
russia's illegal annexation of crimea in
2014 uh canada did indeed impose
sanctions on more than 440 individuals
and entities many in coordination with
our allies uh just to give you some
subtext on that mr speaker canada has
sanctioned 120 individuals and 81
entities related to russia's violation
of the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine and we have
sanctioned 202 individuals and 42
entities related to russia's illegal
annexation of crimea and the ongoing
russian occupation in parts of eastern
ukraine and we have been very clear as a
government mr speaker should russia
increase its aggression in ukraine it
will be met with stiff and severe
economic sanctions in coordination with
our international partners
thank you mr speaker and i i would like
to
highlight as many have done the
important contribution of the ukrainian
canadian community to building
the prairies and alberta and and that
community continues to add so much to
the vibrancy of of the prairies i wonder
uh if the minister
could comment on what he is hearing on
the ground we know that in alberta there
are 370
000 ukrainian canadians living in the
province i am sure that the minister is
bringing their voices
to cabinet and
i would like to hear from the minister
what uh specific requests
are they
uh making to him and would they like to
see
from our government
the honorable minister of tourism
thank you very much mr speaker and i
thank the parliamentary secretary to the
minister of tourism and associate
minister of finance for the very kind
question and i i see that the member of
parliament for winnipeg south is there
even with his hand up and i have to say
mr speaker that
he was the moderator of a very
moving and important uh conversation a
town hall a zoom town hall that we held
across the west with the minister of
foreign affairs the deputy prime
minister
the minister of emergency preparedness
the mp for winnipeg south centre as well
we had 500 people in that zoom and i
mean 130 some years of of immigrant
of waves of immigrants of ukrainians
means that if you're in the west
you you probably eat holochi you eat
petah like i go to french canadian
weddings and i can tell you mr speaker
that ukrainian food is a staple
and uh it's because we're all admitted
together and and the community is
nervous it's it's frightened it's a it's
afraid for the people and the family
that they have in ukraine and they have
asked us to stay very close to what the
ukrainian government has asked us to do
that is why uh
look in in maybe a historic amount of
time our government was able to deliver
on 120 million dollar loan and i thank
the deputy prime minister and minister
of um foreign affairs for that so we are
going to watch the situation carefully
we're going to stay very uh closely
connected to uh community leaders like
the ukrainian canadian congress uh both
here in edmonton and calgary and alberta
across the west and across the country
continuing debate uh the honorable minis
of the honorable member for wellington
halton hills
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i'll be
splaying my time with the member for
lakeland
mr speaker canada's security
is inextricably linked to that of
europe's and it has been
from
for centuries
where once
the conflicts between the french and
british empires had a direct impact us
on us here
on this continent conflicts between the
spanish empire
and other empires had a direct impact on
our security here in this continent
to today
where our security is inextricably
linked to that of europe's
mr speaker in the last century
in the first and second world wars
canada's security was inextricably
linked to that
of europe we all know the names
of where canadian blood was shed in
defense of this country and its values
names like passchendaele vimy ridge the
battle of the sum
think about the second world war
and the names that are indelibly etched
into the minds of canadians names like
juno beach
in north normandy
in arnhem
in fact it was canadian soldiers
who in 1945 liberated the netherlands
some seven thousand canadian soldiers
died in the canals the fields and the
villages of the netherlands
liberating the dutch
from
the tyranny of nazism
in the 20th century
some one hundred thousand canadians died
defending this country
in two world wars sixty thousand
canadians died
on the battlefields of france in the
first world war some forty thousand
canadians died
around the world during the second world
war most of them in europe
and almost all of those canadians
are buried in graves that dot
the normandy coastline the fields of
normandy the netherlands
italy and so many other places
throughout europe
and after the first world war
because of the blood that had been shed
canada began
to gain her independence
the balfour declaration
led to the treaty of westminster and
eventually to canada's independence
from the united kingdom
and after the second world war because
of the high price we paid
we were a founding member in 1949 of the
north atlantic treaty organization
canada was and continues to play a key
role
in peace and security across europe in
fact canada has contributed to every
single nato mission
since the alliance's inception in 1949
we are the only
we are one of only two countries that
are the non-european members
of the nato alliance and now mr speaker
nato is being threatened an estimated
130 000 russian troops are built up on
the ukrainian border
but we've we have a government that has
failed to take any real action to
support ukraine
we are facing a situation today of grave
consequence while the government on
january 21st announced a loan of 120
million dollars to ukraine and while
they recently announced the extension
and expansion of operation unifier they
have failed
to grant the key request of the
government of ukraine which is to
provide lethal defensive weapons
to ukraine for her defense
the united states has provided some 650
million in defense equipment 200 million
of which is lethal aid for ukraine the
united kingdom has supplied lethal
aid lethal weapons in the form of
anti-tank weapons
others such as poland lithuania latvia
estonia and the czech republic also have
provided lethal weapons
mr speaker diplomacy not backed up
by credible threats of the use of
military force
and in limited and rare
circumstances the use of that force is
naive talk
and empty rhetoric and that empty talk
and rhetoric that will result in damage
to canada's security
and the security of europe and ukraine
that's what a previous generation of
canadians understood
in 1945 when they created the north
atlantic treaty organization out of the
bloodshed that had happened in the
previous 50 years
that's not something that this current
prime minister understands who've said
that this will only be solved through
diplomacy and not through the threat
of force to defend democracy and so mr
speaker
i urge the government to get off its
naive position defend the rules-based
international order and ensure that
lethal defensive weaponry is provided to
a democracy to ukraine in order to
uphold that order thank you
question a commander questions and
comments the honorable member for
scarborough guildwood thank you mr
speaker i think you all remember for his
speech which was thoughtful and
historical and
and i wanted to
get his views on a
quote by henry kissinger
where
nations don't have
friends or enemies they only have
interests
and i'd like him to articulate
why as the member from etobicoke center
did
why it is in canada's best interest
that we give full-throated support to
ukraine
honourable member for wellington halton
hills
well thank you mr speaker the answer to
the question is simple for centuries
canada's security
the safety and security of our citizens
the safety of our security of our
borders is inextricably tied to that of
europe and
if europe is being threatened if
democracies in europe are being
threatened
with an attack with invasion then canada
must
must stand up
not only for
the security of those nations in europe
but for the security of canadians here
at home
and provide all assistance necessary to
ensure that happens
assistance
including diplomacy humanitarian aid and
assistance including
the threat of use of force
and lethal defensive weapons as the
government of ukraine has requested
question a commentary questions and
comments uh the honorable member for
inter lake uh selkirk into lake eastman
thank you mr speaker i want to thank my
uh colleague uh shuttle minister for
foreign affairs uh the mp for for uh
all or
never mind child minister frank just
went
rained out there i i'll just say this
that uh he has been just a a great
reasonable voice on foreign affairs in
our caucus and in this house and i know
that uh he takes uh what's happening in
ukraine very seriously as he just
articulated and i
i know
if he could just elaborate more that the
world is watching what happens right now
in ukraine death spots around the world
are waiting to see what nato and the
alliance does in response to these
threats from the russian federation and
vladimir putin in particular and if we
are not able to contain the situation
and protect ukraine's
sovereign territory and the people of
ukraine
what possibly could happen
by other despots who see the position
canada has taken and other nations as
weak
for wellington halton hills
well thank you mr speaker i couldn't
agree with my colleague more in fact
what is going on right now often uh
reminds me
of the spanish civil war of the 1930s
where the duly elected and recognized
government of spain the republican
government of spain was under threat
from the nationalists from a civil war
and a coup d'etat that had erupted
led by
spanish generals
and spanish republicans pleaded
to western democracies to provide lethal
defensive weapons lethal military
weapons for the defense
of spanish republicans
but democracies in the 1930s turned a
blind eye and refused
those military weapons
but germany
in italy mean fascist powers of the time
sent plenty of weapons to the
nationalists who eventually triumphed
leading
into
the dark events of the war
of
1939-1945
and when i hear about governments
democracies refusing to send lethal
defensive weapons
to a fellow democracy under threat from
another authoritarian regime
it brings me back to that period of time
in the 1930s where we as democracies
turned a blind eye to rising
authoritarianism in europe and paid a
very high price over the subsequent six
years to 1945 and that is the lesson we
have failed to heed from the situation
that's currently unfolding in eastern
europe
reprise dude continuing debate the
honourable member for lakeland thank you
mr speaker and to the member for
wellington halton hills for his
leadership and this opportunity
this debate is urgent and personal
lakeland has deep connections with
ukraine in 1891 125 ukrainian families
first came to lamont county called the
cradle of ukrainian settlement in canada
where i grew up in 1903 my
father-in-law's saskiw family came by
train to innisfree to farm by 1930 the
more than 50 thousands ukraine 50 000
ukrainians in alberta were the biggest
community outside ukraine it's as strong
as ever in lakeland from churches
festivals the ukrainian village and the
ancestral home built by former premier
ed stelmak's grandparents the victorious
settlement near smokey lake saint paul's
garlic dome to the world's largest
pessica in vegaville glendon's giant
pierogi manders kubaza symbols of
ukrainian food faith family language and
culture helped define lakeland
today outside of ukraine and russia
canada has the world's largest ukrainian
population more than a million people
historically canada stood with ukraine
to defend territory and democracy almost
three decades ago under prime minister
brian mulroney's progressive
conservative government canada was the
first western country to recognize
ukraine's independence from russia only
one day after an overwhelming
declaration from the ukrainian people
canada's support was immediate and
unequivocal
in 2014 russia's illegal occupation of
crimea was met with a swift power
powerful response from prime minister
stephen harper's conservative government
he led the charge to boot russia out of
the g8 pledged millions of dollars in
military trainers and other aid and
imposed sweeping sanctions against
hundreds of individuals and entities he
didn't pull any punches with putin at
the g20 later that year and told him to
his face to get out of ukraine he said
quote whether it takes five months or
fifty years canada will never accept the
illegal occupation of ukrainian
territory by russia
two years ago he warned quote ukraine's
struggle is not over we must continue to
stand with the people of ukraine in the
face of ongoing aggression from the
putin regime
today those prophetic words fall on the
deaf ears of this liberal government
like the pleas from ukrainians in
lakeland and across canada natalia from
vagabill emailed me she wants canada to
take a leadership role in support of
ukraine's independence and the defense
of ukraine's territory to increase
sanctions and military equipment and
defensive weapons for ukraine among
other measures
vagorville has significant ukrainian
history and is a sister city to call
amaya ukraine last spring vega roll
hosted the red carpet premiere of troy
ruptash his award-winning film they who
surround us which tells the story of a
grieving ukrainian farmer in alberta who
loses his wife in a tragic accident he
really relives trauma from his childhood
in ukraine and being dragged from his
home with his sister and mother by
russian invading invaders when it ended
there wasn't a dry eye in the room the
people of lakeland are standing with
ukraine and they expect their government
to do the same
a constituent janet wrote to me
imploring the canadian government to do
more she said that ukrainians quote have
the will and passion to fight but not
the army to defend against russia's
might needlessly young people and their
future will die if the world does not
help we must not forget them well
conservatives will not abandon ukraine
nor will we forget the ukrainian people
last april we condemned russia's
expansion of its illegal military
presence in crimea and called on the
liberals to counter with an increase in
military defensive aid and re-offer
radarsat imaging to help id russian
troop and equipment movements two weeks
ago in response to another buildup of
russian troops at ukraine's border
conservatives again called on the
liberals to expand operation unifier
restore radar sat imaging give ukraine
lethal defensive weapons and use
magnitsky sanctions the liberals first
only offered a small loan that was
politely welcomed by ukraine's president
then non-lethal equipment a small
expansion of operation ufi nurse
standard renewal some humanitarian
assistance and only 60 troops that's not
enough
ukraine is facing 130 000 russian troops
their embassy said quote we need to
defend our land the uk and us have
already sent military equipment we would
appreciate if canada follows suit the
liberals are pure ready to fall short
again in another abrogation of canada's
proud heritage of actually leading and
adjoining allies when it matters most
for generations canadians have been
world renowned for extraordinary efforts
defending freedom equality democracy
human rights and sovereignty punching
above our weight no matter the strength
of the foe those values that courage and
that moral compass it's still in the
hearts of the canadian people the
canadian armed forces
and our international diplomatic service
the liberal government must stand with
ukraine and with all ukrainian canadians
with real action
thank you
question only come ontario questions and
comments the honourable member for
etobicoke center
thanks very much speaker and i'd like to
thank the member for uh for her
intervention and
and uh it was um it was really wonderful
to hear
uh particularly in the first part of of
uh her remarks uh sharing uh a little
bit about her community in lakeland and
and the ukrainian heritage that so many
of the people in lakeland uh
value and share and how they celebrate
that and how that inspires their concern
for what's happening right now in
ukraine
i'm wondering if um if the member could
speak a little bit to sanctions she
mentioned it briefly in her remarks
but she mentioned briefly the need for
for sanctions and i'm wondering um you
know obviously over the course of over
the course of the last few years the
government has sanctioned about 440
individuals and entities
mostly russian but some ukrainian of
course as well who are involved in in
threatening ukraine's sovereignty
and violating human rights i'm just
wondering if she could speak to what
additional sanctions she would like to
see and as any particular groups or
entities she would like sanction
member for lakeland
yeah i'd like to thank the member for
his question uh for his for his question
for his comments
i guess i would say that it's not only
about sanctions the response of the
canadian government must be
multi-pronged sanctions are only one
part of the vast array of tools that
canada has to show real solidarity to
defend the sovereignty and the territory
territorial integrity of ukraine and
uh the request is very clear as the top
priority for lethal weapons when not at
least nine other countries in the world
including the us and the uk have ensured
that that military equipment that the
ukrainian people require to defend
themselves is there canada should be at
the front of the pack
christianity come onto our questions and
comments the honourable member for
edmonton strathcona thank you mr speaker
and i would like to thank my my
colleague the member from lakeland um i
know that that she has you know as as
many ukrainians in her constituency as i
do in mine and and
um it was it was lovely to hear that
that commitment to the to the ukrainian
diaspora and her community
uh you know
she won't be surprised when i talk about
the need for de-escalation and the need
for peaceful resolution on this conflict
and what i would like to just hear from
her is she spoke about the the tools
that we have in our toolbox and all of
the things that we could be doing from
her perspective as a member of the
conservative party what are those things
that canada should be doing to
de-escalate aside from providing weapons
aside from escalating with lethal force
weapons what are those things that she
sees the the government should be doing
to de-escalate to turn down the
temperature on the on the conflict
that's happening in ukraine
the
honorable member for lakeland thank you
to the member for her for her comments
and her question as well i outlined a
number of those specific measures that
canada could take and that conservatives
have consistently uh recommended
since last april which is a lot of time
that has expended with very limited
action while ukrainians are vulnerable
to expanding russian military forces on
the border but given that she commented
about my constituent my constituents why
did i just tell you a few
recommendations that natalia from
bakerville sent me these are things that
conservatives support too she said
accelerated nato membership action plan
for ukraine increase sanctions on russia
to deter further aggression ensure that
the nordstream 2 pipeline never becomes
operational increase the provision of
military equipment and defensive weapons
to ukraine extend and expand operation
unifier canada's military training
mission in ukraine of course launched by
the former conservative government
the as uh the member for wellington
halton hills said diplomacy is critical
and must be ongoing but to push back on
the danger and the threats to free
people and free countries everywhere
against despots it must be founded by
real potential lethal action
stella come out eric questions and
comments say the honourable member for
san juan
thank you mr speaker i'd like to thank
my colleague for her speech we've heard
i think my colleague needs to put in
here
[Music]
would that really make a big difference
that is a challenge well of course
diplomacy is necessary and ought to be
ongoing but let's talk about the real
cost to the ukrainian people of only
talking natalia also pointed out since
2014 this illegal invasion and
occupation of russia has cost ukraine
over thirteen thousand dead over thirty
thousand wounded and one point five
million internationally inter internally
displaced people so this is why we
should join our free and democratic
allies who have already sent the weapons
to ukraine that they need to defend
themselves this is why we should be at
the front of the pack because those are
the real costs that happen while we
put up hashtags on pieces of paper and
sit around here debating diplomacy thank
you mr speaker representative continuing
debate the honourable member for
etobicoke lakeshore thank you very much
mr speaker uh the first thing i would
like to say
is thank you to all members of this
house
tonight because this debate would not be
taking place if it wasn't for the
unanimous agreement from all members in
this chamber
[Applause]
and i believe the reason we have that
unanimous consent is that we stand
united in purpose standing with ukraine
and we need to remember that throughout
this debate mr speaker
i rise today in support of ukraine and
if the initiatives of our government to
support ukraine in this difficult time
the links between our two countries are
strong and canada has been and will be
steadfast in standing in solidarity with
ukraine especially in the face of
unwarranted russian aggression
for me mr speaker the ties are strong
not only not only do i have a large
ukrainian community in my constituency
many ukrainian cultural and religious
organizations as well as the ukrainian
consulate
canadians
of ukrainian descent strengthen our
social and cultural fabric
in etobicoke in toronto and in the
country
the community is strong and the ties
bind our two countries are many
they are my neighbors
they are my teammates they are my
classmates they are my friends
as has been said many times mr speaker
in 1991 when ukraine became an
independent state canada was the first
western country to recognize ukraine
canada and ukraine have enjoyed an even
stronger relationship since
the 1994 joint declaration on special
partnership recognizes canada's support
for the development of ukraine and the
importance of that bilateral cooperation
canada is committed to supporting
ukraine as it takes necessary steps to
secure itself as a stable democratic and
prosperous country
we've been there developed we've been
there to develop and strengthen
democratic institutions in ukraine
including election monitoring
i was there in 2019 myself as part of
the delegation mr speaker i felt those
bonds
since 2014 canada has provided ukraine
with more more than 890 million dollars
in multi-faceted assistance to support
ukraine's security prosperity and reform
objectives
since 2015 canada has been providing
military training training to ukraine
under operation unifier
the operation's focus is to assist with
security force training which helps them
improve and build their capability and
capacity
over 32 thousand of their security
forces to help ensure ukraine remain
sovereign secure and stable
last week our government announced 340
million dollars for the extension and
expansion of operation unifier
for three more years
as well as immensely deploying
immediately deploying 60 personnel to
join approximately 200 canadian armed
forces members on the ground with the
ability to surge to 400.
military support is just one part of
canada's overall strategy
their economic supports through trade
and investment in 2020 the value of
canada's merchandise exports ukraine
totaled 161 million dollars and the
value of merchandise imports from
ukraine amounted to 144 million dollars
last week
january 27th
canada and ukraine announced the launch
of negotiations for the modernization of
the canada eu trade ukraine free trade
agreement
since 2014 canada has been one of
ukraine's leading bilateral de
development assistant partners having
committed more than 245 million dollars
in development assistance including the
provision
of emergency basic health services safe
drinking water food assistance
protection support shelter essential
relief
items
mr speaker i'll end this way
this needs to be a non-partisan debate
i i neglected to say
the honor the honorable member for
lake shore i was getting to that i was
saving that for the end
but as i said at the beginning mr
speaker
we are united in purpose
the prime minister is fully engaged the
deputy prime minister is fully engaged
our minister of foreign affairs was in
ukraine last week and came back and
granted the request of the president of
ukraine
the minister of defense is there as we
speak i expect upon her return
we will see further action from canada
mr speaker i hope we can maintain this
united force and non-partisan approach
thank you you're here
question i come ontario questions and
comments uh the honourable member of
pitt meadows maple ridge
um
i've heard the
liberal members discuss about all
all
options being on the table
but
it seems to me that one of the options
is the
is providing military
aid lethal support and we've been
bringing this over and over again and i
think there's a good
uh an example of the previous
member of parliament with the liberal
party former lieutenant general andrew
leslie that said
uh recently that the liberal government
does not take the military for ser
seriously and this is impacting this
impacts what we can do and provide for
uh ukrainians having a direct effect so
that that is my concern it's just this
is actually an outflow what we're able
to do for the ukraine other than you
know
uh a few different you know a few troops
coming in and doing a few different
things like this of what we can actually
do as far as military which is what they
need uh help with so i'm wondering if
the member for etobicoke can can speak
about the deterioration of the military
and just the ornaments uh we have we
have in order to provide the ukraine
for etobicoke lakeshore well first of
all i'm going to disagree with this
characterization of the of the situation
there's been no
diminished contribution canada has been
there with ukraine since the beginning
this goes back to 2014
with the invasion of crimea
we've been talking about support of
military lethal weapons
canada didn't do it then
the opposition is asking us to do it now
so military support comes in many
different uh fashions and we need only
look at operation unifier mr speaker
over 3000 over 30 000 members of the
ukrainian military are better trained
because of canada's contribution so to
say that canada hasn't helped with
military contribution is it absolutely
false mr speaker
tara the honourable member for edmonton
strathcona
thank you mr speaker i think there was a
miscommunication in our in our ranks
over here um i would like to thank the
member for his interventions today and
and one of the things that i had
asked earlier and i'd like to extend the
question to him as well is around the
the assurance by the government of
canada that they will be implementing
some of those key lessons in our
feminist foreign policy
and one of those is that we do what we
can to advocate to ensure women are at
all tables that women are part of all of
the discussions that lead to
de-escalation because we know that when
women are at the table different
decisions are made and i just want to be
very very clear how is this government
ensuring that women are there that they
are part of of the solution they're part
of the de-escalation efforts that are
happening in ukraine the honourable
member for etobicoke lakeshore thank you
mr speaker i'd like to thank the member
for an excellent question we heard the
prime minister earlier this evening
addressed that very issue
canada is very proud to support the
initiative to make sure that women form
part of the training exercise
you look at operation unifier women form
part of that training
international development programs that
canada supported and been part of have
put great emphasis on that very issue
uh i think it's quite clear where canada
stands thank you well done christine
come out
the deputy the honorable member for
senjohn
thank you mr
speaker my colleague for his speech
something that's come up a lot this
evening is the importance of diplomacy
in finding a solution for this company
some think that the diplomacy should be
the priority others think that it should
be secondary
and
with all due respect mr speaker um to
suggest that there's been a shortfall by
canada on the diplomacy front is just
simply wrong
our foreign affairs minister was in
ukraine last week our defense minister
left ukraine hours ago
she's going to brussels as we speak
to engage in further diplomatic
discussions that's exactly the approach
canada is trying to take but did they
answer the question what is a priority
everything is a priority to make sure
that further invasion of ukraine doesn't
take place thank you mr speaker
continuing debate the honourable member
for davenport
thank you mr speaker i want to i want to
wish you and all colleagues in the house
a very happy new year i know it's the
end of january but it's my first chance
to stand in this house virtually to
speak and to send those wishes your way
i'm very grateful for the opportunity to
speak on this take note debate on
ukraine and the build-up of russian
troops along the ukrainian border it's
important for us to have this
conversation and dialogue
mr speaker we live in troubling and
unpredictable times
in addition to the global pandemic that
the world is grappling with
what is happening at the ukrainian
border with the accumulation and the
buildup of over 100 000 troops by russia
is troubling to say in the least
as a ukrainian canadian i've been
following this development since uh
since its start last fall
my father's family is ukrainian they
were and are very proud of their culture
and heritage they came to canada as a
broken family after world war ii
reluctantly leaving their homeland and
having no choice
they lost everything in the war and with
the then ussr taking over ukraine there
was no hope for a future they were
devastated from a displaced person's
camp and on one of the last boats to
leave for north america they came to
canada seeking peace and safety
the scars from the war and from that
time remain with my family and we are
still healing from them
which is why i am so very proud of our
federal government for its leadership
and for stepping up to help ukraine
counter unprovoked russian aggression
i support canada's strong push for peace
and for a diplomatic resolution
while supporting ukraine economically
and helping ukraine to defend itself
for me the right choice is to push hard
and to explore any and every opportunity
for a diplomatic resolution
providing arms should be our last option
not our first one i stand with canada
and with our government to defend the
sovereignty territoriality and
independence of ukraine i fully support
canada's push for peace and for a
diplomatic resolution while preparing if
we have to to quickly step up our
contributions should russia choose armed
conflict and to invade ukrainian
territory
as well as i'm currently serving as the
vice president of the nato parliamentary
association i'm also very proud of
nato's leadership under the direction of
secretary general uh jens stallenberg
nato has been very clear that they are
encouraging and are prepared to engage
in political dialogue with russia while
also being ready to respond if russia
chooses an armed conflict
now let's look at how canada's stepping
up to support ukraine and there's many
ways when our minister of foreign
affairs went to ukraine over a week ago
ukrainian president zielinski's number
one ask was for economic loans to help
stabilize ukraine's economy within three
days our government stepped up with a
hundred and twenty million dollar loan
the second thing ukrainian uh zielinski
ukrainian president zielinski asked for
was to help defend ukraine and so we
urgently announced an expansion of the
existing much valued operation unifier
at the cost 200 of 340 million dollars
this extension and expansion of canada's
military presence in support of ukraine
will ensure that members of the
ukrainian of the canadian armed forces
will continue to provide enhanced
military training and mentorship to
ukraine security forces through to the
end of march 20 2025. additionally
canada's providing non-lethal aid and
working with the canadian security
establishment to enhance cyber
operations this increased support will
help ukraine strengthen its security and
ability to defend itself against a range
of threats and on top of that we're also
providing 50 million of uh
of development and humanitarian aid to
ukraine so mr speaker in less than one
week over 500 million in ukraine in
support for ukraine
our minister of foreign affairs who's
been in constant contact with our
many nato allies have indicated that we
are ready to step up even more
together with our allies with stronger
economic sanctions against russia should
there be military incursion into ukraine
any action by russia in this direction
will have serious consequences
consequences our minister of national
defense have said the same thing i want
to say to both ministers how grateful i
am for their extraordinary leadership
during these unpredictable and troubling
times in closing mr speaker while we
live in troubling and unpredictable
times i have confidence that working
together with nato and our other allies
and in keeping the channels of
communication open with russia i truly
do believe that it is not too late to
find a diplomatic and peaceful way out
of the current situation
thank you mr speaker you know a kamala
tara the honourable member for
wellington halton hills
thank you mr speaker i just have a
comment for uh
the member who i've known for a number
of years now
russia's military is not the only hard
power tool that it has to intimidate
europe and ukraine
it can use energy as a weapon it
supplies europe's forty percent of
europe's natural gas
and if it cuts off natural gas supplies
to europe people will freeze industries
will shut down and european gdp will
plummet the bite administration has been
talking to countries around the world
about increasing natural gas supplies to
europe in the event that the russians
cut off gas to europe except for canada
canada's not mentioned in any of the
reports coming back about supplying
natural gas in the event that this
happens even though that we are the
fifth largest natural gas producer in
the world
so my question
is when will the government see that
energy is not only vital to our economy
it's vital to our national security into
that of europe and to that of ukraine
member for davenport
uh thank you so much mr speaker and i do
want to thank the honorable member for
his excellent uh commenting question um
i do believe that we recognize the
importance of energy um i do believe
that
uh if we if if he is suggesting that we
should be looking at energy as one of
the ways that we might actually want to
support ukraine in the future i think
that our prime minister uh all of our
ministers have spoken today many of my
colleagues who have spoken today have
indicated that every option is on the
table and anything that we can do to
continue to support ukraine to con
continue to de-escalate um will be on
the table and will be part of the
discussions moving forward thank you mr
speaker question and come on tyre the
honourable member for edmonton
strathcona
thank you very much mr speaker and i'd
like to thank the colleague for her for
her intervention this evening um in in
the previous intervention there was some
discussion about canada and its efforts
with regards to diplomacy and our
diplomatic core
i'm not i'm not referring to ministers
going for visits to ukraine i'm not
referring to that at all i'm referring
about our diminished diplomatic corps so
under the conservatives we had massive
cuts on our diplomatic corps especially
when global affairs um became became
something when they took away trade and
development and put it all into one
place we lost a lot of our diplomacy and
our ability to do diplomacy and our
ability to have that that role in the
world um and we didn't see that be built
back up we also haven't seen our
international development and our oda be
built up we also haven't seen you know
our peacekeeping efforts be built up so
so what i want to know from the
government is
will they commit to doing these things
building back our peacekeeping um
building back our diplomatic core
building back our international
development so that the canada can be
back and we can be better suited for for
future um
future conflicts like the one that we're
seeing right now in ukraine
global member for davenport
uh thank you so much mr speaker and i
want to thank the honourable member for
her question
i will say to you that i do believe that
our government since we've been first
elected in late 2015 has very much put
an emphasis on diplomacy on on
strengthening diplomacy i think
throughout this whole um
uh situation with the uh the build up of
russian aggression at the ukrainian
borders i think we have had excellent
diplomatic efforts from our prime
minister from our minister foreign
affairs from our minister of national
defense from a number of of my
colleagues and i think that that is an
area that we will continue to strengthen
i'll also say to you that one of the
other
things that we've announced is that
canada is creating a team out of global
affairs canada to support further
coordination of federal efforts in
support of peace and security in ukraine
and i think that we are trying to do
everything we can everything we can to
continue to expand our diplomatic
efforts to continue to open the lines of
communication to our allies to nato to
anyone who wants to help find a
diplomatic uh salute and peaceful
solution um out of the current situation
that we find ourselves in right now
thank you you have time for a very short
question and uh answer the honourable
member for winnipeg south
well thank you mr speaker and thanks uh
thank you member for her
thanks to the member for her very
passionate and informed speech the
minister of tourism uh referred earlier
to a town hall of 500 ukrainian
canadians hosted by the deputy prime
minister and our our minister of foreign
affairs and we're hearing many of the
things that we're hearing tonight of
course but we heard from the ministers a
theme very similar to yours tonight
canada being flexible and resilient in
response open to new options as the
situation evolves and i think we've
heard that message from
our minister of defense today is is that
uh something that you share and that we
should be open to new options
honorable member for davenport very
short answer
thank you so much i i want to say thanks
to the honorable member for for his
comment and first question i absolutely
agree with you
uh i believe that we're absolutely open
to all questions we are looking for and
as i said i'm an eternal optimist i
absolutely believe that there's still a
way for us to find a peaceful and
diplomatic solution and i think we have
the right approach here in canada and
i'm proud of our leadership and i'm
hopeful uh that we will find a a
solution moving forward thank you
praise your devout continuing debate the
honourable member for south surrey white
rock
thank you mr speaker i will be sharing
my time with the member for thornhill
the russians are ready for war with
ukraine and have the elements of 10
combined arms and tank armies
surrounding ukraine's borders the
russians say they are normal troop
deployments and they are not looking to
invade ukraine they said the same things
in 2014 before they seized crimea and
the donbass with georgia in 2008 they
said that their military buildup was a
war game and they took the northern part
of the country by storm
this time we know different about
russian president vladimir putin's
claims
typically only three russian armies are
stationed opposite ukraine and now we
are seeing units from six other combined
arms armies and the main strike force of
the western military district the first
guards tank army move within miles of
the russian ukrainian border
more russian troops have been sent to
belarus along with fighter aircraft to
both deter nato and to threaten a
northern invasion march on kiev
belarus's army is on a heightened state
of alert and ready to join russia in
battle
russian forces
in transnistria have also been built up
between five and six large russian
amphibious ships are on the way to the
black sea with naval infantry
smaller amphibious craft are coming by
road
russian pipeline troops have been
deployed forward to establish
fuel hubs for their armored forces the
russian navy is engaged in war games in
the atlantic and pacific ocean and the
north baltic and black seas
russia's strategic rocket forces are in
war games on a heightened state of alert
and dispersed
and blood has been sent to russian field
hospitals the last thing that happens
before they become battle ready blood is
such a precious commodity that we use
colored water in exercises
my husband and children are part
ukrainian
my heart is with that vulnerable
democracy and its people
my heart is with the men women and
families of canadian armed forces that
may be put in harm's way
the us uk and other nato states are
ready to deploy forces to deter the
russian
and belarusian aggressors so what about
canada in 2019 the prime minister
announced in london
canada's contribution to nato's high
readiness force
canada's total commitment to the nato
readiness initiative
includes 12 cf-18 fighter jets an
expeditionary air task force a maritime
patrol aircraft three frigates a
submarine a mechanized infantry
battalion a mobile hospital and a
platoon for chemical biological
radiological and nuclear defense
right now in the face of unprecedented
russian aggression against ukraine and
hybrid warfare directed at poland and
the baltic states through their proxy
belarus we have a 550 person force in
estonia helping to train and protect
that vulnerable nato state
we have 200 trainers in ukraine with a
couple hundred more maybe on their way
and a small special forces detachment
and the minister just announced that
they are moving out of harm's way west
of the dinipra river we have one warship
hmcs montreal in transit to the black
sea and one being made ready in halifax
the government has watched the russian
military build up in real terms since
several 2021 in september we have had
months to put together a robust list of
both non-lethal and lethal aid to
support ukraine it may not be a nato
member state but it is surely a nato
ally at this stage we should be
supplying lethal defensive aid to help
this fledgling democracy stand up to the
bully of central and eastern europe in
vladimir putin as well the cyber
defensive capabilities and our
strategy establishment should be
leveraged to help ukraine as well
canadians
signals intelligence could be invaluable
to monitoring russian interactions the
satellite intelligence from radarsat
would be most helpful in tracking troop
movements the canadian armed forces can
provide training in a much wider range
of lethal combat skills than they are
doing now and canada should start as
quick as ukraine can accommodate extra
help
even a maritime patrol aircraft to
monitor russian actions in the black sea
and baltic
would be helpful at this point
sorry am i out of time madame speaker
can i just say my last sentence said
if canadians care at all about democracy
if we care about freedom and sovereignty
we must care about it everywhere
thank you i did try to
provide singles but
questions and comments questions
the honourable london fan show
thank you madam speaker
i thank the honorable colleague
and my colleague on the defense
committee
for her contribution tonight i wanted to
ask her we've we've talked a lot about
that this in the house in terms of the
failure of the of the liberal government
to provide leadership for um the women
especially about both men and women in
the armed forces and um they're told
that this is taken on retention on
recruitment of those armed forces so as
we talk about an additional stress of uh
which i agree with entirely to expand uh
the um operation unifier but maybe we
could talk about and she could address
the additional stresses that is this is
going to put on the men and women in our
armed forces thank you madam speaker
uh the honourable member for south
surrey white rock
thank you madam speaker and thank you to
my colleague for her question and of
course this is a crucial issue within
our canadian armed forces right now one
which madam justice arbor is tasked with
to look at further recommendations
because the earlier recommendations were
not all put in place and we are looking
for
further insights there
we are
we need more personnel in the canadian
armed forces and retention and
recruitment are a huge issue but we do
have serving men and women who are
trained and we do know that they can do
even more to help train in ukraine and
in vulnerable democracies like ukraine
who we should as i said this is there
may they may not be part of nato at
least yet but they're surely a nato ally
okay questions and comments questions
oh the honourable member for etobicoke
thank you very much madam speaker and um
and i'm wondering if you know i
appreciated the member's remarks and i'm
wondering if she could speak to
uh you know one of the things that the
government has done
uh over the past number of years is
impose sanctions on a range of of
individuals and entities
um who've either violated human rights
or contributed to violating ukraine's
sovereignty uh we we know that in
in crimea for example there are
tremendous human rights abuses against
the crimean tatars by the now occupying
uh russian uh forces and administrations
uh democracy is being repressed etc so
sanctions have been imposed for a number
of reasons on on on russian officials
and entities i'm wondering what your
thoughts are about the role of sanctions
going forward and if if you believe
sanctions are needed uh are there
particular groups of folks or types of
folks that you believe should be
sanctioned
and i just want to remind that you all
remember that he's to address all
questions and comments through the chair
the honourable member for south surrey
white rock well thank you for your
question and of course sanctions i
believe do work and diplomacy usually
works but we are dealing with a very
aggressive
country that has decided that in their
interests whatever they deem them to be
that ukraine is part of their going
forward and you know diplomacy should
always come first and sanctions along
with diplomacy absolutely are a
deterrent but offering ukraine every
support short of assistance i suggest is
not good enough we have to stand
stronger with ukraine and democracy
questions
[Music]
for ourselves but also to share with
allies
for south surrey white rock
thank you my colleague i absolutely
agree it's essential and you may have
noticed that the russians shut down a
lot of ukraine's cyber
abilities before
stepping up even further
with aggression so this is a
part of modern warfare and it's
something that's going on all the time
by aggressor states and we need to do
more to be alive to it monitor it and
prevent it thanks
so i do want to remind the honourable
member as well that when she's answering
questions that she's to address it to
the chair and not directly to the
members it appeases
the honourable member for thornhill
thank you madam speaker i want to uh
thank the honorable member from south
surrey white rock for her views on the
debate
and with that i'm pleased to rise in
this house to speak to a matter that i
know canadians are watching not only
those of ukrainian roots but all of
those who believe in moral clarity and
principled approach to our country's
foreign policy and our place in the
world and canadians like me madam
speaker who have pieced together a
first-hand history from the family
dinner table of stories from the past
that make today's threat so clear and
obvious
mr speaker if there was ever an instance
where canada where the prime minister
where the foreign minister had the
opportunity to do the right thing it was
last week
this government could have lent its
support to ukraine against the russian
aggression by providing ukraine with the
lethal defensive weapons they need they
did not
the government of the us the uk poland
lithuania czech republic estonia latvia
and others have already provided that
support
some have leaned on our past refusal to
arm ukraine as an excuse not to do it
today but the difference is now that
almost nine years have passed since
continued occupation began
the constant escalation of aggression
from and of of course from all of our
nato allies
we now know the situation has changed
rapidly in the last week so it becomes
very difficult to understand why canada
has not joined our allies in fact the
government has recognized this
themselves by operational changes we
heard about yesterday mr speaker it's
important for the house to understand
the history of our relationship and the
history that many members of this house
will remember firsthand because it was
not that long ago that canada was
unafraid of principle
and ukraine's most vocal ally in the g7
and today
that is not so distant uh in memory and
it will be replaced where a history
where we are an observer to an imminent
threat that we know to be true
and we have two clear options we treat
ukraine as the allies that they are as
defenders of democracy and freedom who
we would lend our full military support
to
on the path to european integration or
we excuse ourselves from the
conversation to appease putin's
violence and walk away
and i know the answer was once clear our
past action on this issue unfortunately
doesn't
seem like the right indicator for our
future action
in the past canada's actions including
included targeted sanctions against
kremlin supporters uh political and
economic support to kiev's government
the redeployment of military assets as
part of nato's uh reassurance package in
eastern europe and the contribution of
observers of course to uh to ukraine's
election but today they need more
uh and our action would have been clear
the steadfast support of our former
prime minister i think was clear he
spoke directly and unambiguously about
his views on putin's occupation and the
destabilizing force that russia is in
the world today
it's important to understand the context
of russia's aggression and the very
nature of its renegade ruler
he's a dangerous dictator uninterested
in looking forward but malevolently
looks backward
uh in the expansion of the russian
empire of the eventual expansion of the
russian empire a violent aggressor to
which diplomacy has always been
answered with hostility
further to the obvious truth which i
think the finance minister and deputy
prime minister understands better than
almost anybody in this place there was a
valiant effort on the part of two
american presidents to try to make putin
a constructive partner with some version
of diplomacy but here's the problem adam
speaker he doesn't want to be
so the response from the government is a
truly curious one first a loan that
might suggest that there was more hope
of bringing back the special
relationship that we once had
followed by an announcement of an
extended training mission that i think
would have been extended anyway but now
on the brink of war
and now without the equipment needed so
over the course of the debate i think
we've heard about canada's unwavering
support but as some of my colleagues
have stated i got i invite the
government to go beyond the words of
support
we have two very clear options for how
we respond we can immediately provide
lethal defensive weapons to ukraine
we can immediately restore
radar sat imaging
and we can use the magnitsky sanctions
against those responsible for russia's
aggression against the ukraine
or we can stand idly by and i believe
that the government truly understands
the threat but i don't believe that they
acted as they do and so maybe it's time
madam speaker
questions and comments
thanks very much madam speaker and um
and i thank the member opposite for for
her remarks
um
it was interesting to hear her speak
about to hear the members speak about um
former prime minister stephen harper i
think she i think the members said that
he spoke unambiguously
um
i
i don't disagree i think he spoke
he spoke unambiguously i think prime
minister trudeau has spoken
unambiguously
um i think our minister of foreign
affairs has spoken unambiguously
one of the things that i think
our prime minister has done in this
proceeds my time in office but during my
time in office as well is that he's also
acted unambiguously
um unambiguously imposing sanctions
unambiguously extending expanding the
training mission and ambiguously
providing additional foreign aid and
ambiguously moving those trainers into
eastern ukraine where they weren't
originally um and ambiguously helping
ukraine to reform so that it could be
stronger and therefore better withstand
the russian invasion um and the design
ambiguously signing a free trade
agreement and so i guess
and after when when when stephen harper
was prime minister he refused to send
those lethal weapons that are now being
asked for and i guess my question is is
um is why
and i do want to correct i said a
tobacco i should have said etobicoke
center uh the owner member for thornhill
i'd like to uh thank the member from
etobicoke center and i know
uh that he is an advocate for the
community and i know that that table
would be better off for having his
advocacy there because i know that he
doesn't agree with the actions that the
government
has uh has has taken i know that he
believes that the government can do more
uh and i do i do want to address one of
the things that he said and and that was
our uh canada's not arming ukraine i
think in 2014 he's probably referring to
and it's because they didn't ask
uh and it's because a lot of things have
changed in almost nine years
uh and that's the that's the reason and
there was an ask and there is a need and
things have gotten uh quite dangerous
and i know this member knows that and i
know this member would believe that and
i know this am member would advocate if
he had a seat at the table
questions and comments the honor member
for europe and melville
yes thank you speaker
i traveled to to give to kiev months
after russia's invasion into crimea and
i met seriously injured soldiers being
treated by canadian surgeons assisting
ukrainian doctors i met with officials
there and since then in canada through
meetings arranged by the then
ambassadorship schenko and they all
asked repeatedly that would our
government please reinstate
our radar satellite systems that could
have made a significant impact on
improving and realizing what russia was
up to back then and even now what we're
facing ukrainians are facing because of
a lack of that oversight i'd like the
member to speak to that fact that our
government truly failed them in that
moment the honorable thornhill
i'd like to thank my honorable colleague
uh for uh for the question and for the
for the comment
um and i would like to uh to speak about
it
uh a little bit more in terms of there
is a there are a number of uh of issues
that have changed on the ground since
uh since the time where probably the
honorable member visited in the last
time uh that we really truly had uh a
debate in this house uh about uh about
the situation in ukraine uh and there
are a lot of things that we can still do
and there are a lot of things that they
have asked for that we have you know
that canada has not provided and there
is an opportunity for the government to
do the right thing and provide those
three things that i spoke about in my uh
and my remarks and believe me this would
be you know on this side of the house we
would absolutely welcome that and i will
be the first to applaud the government
if they did the right thing
we have time for a brief question
resuming debate
the honourable member for scarborough
guilford
thank you madam speaker and i will be um
sharing my time with my former seat mate
the member from etobicoke or from
etobicoke center vancouver center
so the member from waterlooka center
would be surprised to find that he was
my former seat name
uh madam speaker uh it's getting late
um and um
and i just take note that uh the end of
this week is the beginning of the
olympics
and there'll be one nation
out of all the nations in the world that
will not be allowed to compete under its
own flag
and that is the russian nation
finally the olympic committee got sick
of all the corruption and the
uh the doping and and uh cheating and
and uh lying that was coming out of the
russian government
and uh doesn't allow the russian
athletes to compete under their own flag
and this is what
is we meaning the family of nations the
universe of nations canada us
uk
ukraine deals with on on a daily basis
because nothing nothing
happens in russia without vladimir
putin's express permission
and um
so when he would say oh well there's
yeah there might be a hundred thousand
troops on ukraine's border but those are
just exercises and uh there's nothing to
see here that's just that's just
nonsense and no one should should really
pay much attention to it
because he doesn't
speak truth very often
madam speaker
i was once privileged to spend some time
with senator
lisa mukowski
and she has
available to her and i
i don't know is available publicly but a
a map of the arctic and it's like
looking at the arctic from 50 000 feet
above the north pole
and what it shows you
is the
re-militarization of the arctic by the
russian government
all of the refurbished old bases but all
of the new installations as well and
while canada
even from that map is far away from
the russian bases uh nevertheless
uh us is very close the bering strait um
so also is uh finland so also is sweden
so also with greenland so also is uh
denmark so also is uh norway
and the
re-militarization of the arctic in my
judgment madam speaker
is what
it
not in and of itself but it contributes
to why it is in canada's best interest
to
fully participate
in the ukrainian repulsion of this
russian aggression
henry kissinger once said nations don't
have
permanent friends or enemies they only
have interests
and um
regardless of whether you're ukrainian
or you're not ukrainian or whether you
uh have a diaspora in your community or
you don't have diasporan community and
my judgment madam speaker it is in
canada's best interests
that we fully support ukraine
ukraine
[Music]
routine
russia routinely launches
massive cyber attacks on canada
last one being a hospital in
newfoundland and it's nothing but a
mafia shakedown if you pay us millions
of dollars
we'll let you have your hospital back
russia routinely
steals significant amounts of industrial
and commercial intellectual property
russian oligarchs have purchased
significant pieces of industrial and
commercial property in order in order to
whirl deeply into canadian society
and those that money has been generated
from very dubious sources russia is
quite skilled at the game of
misinformation and disinformation
there are many many more reasons why
ukraine security is our security and our
security is
ukraine security
uh madam speaker i'd ask you to cast
your mind
um along the
uh eastern european flank
uh western western russian because if
ukraine goes the next thing to go is
poland and the baltics and when you get
past the pole in the baltics then you go
to finland and then after finland you go
to sweden norway denmark uh and suddenly
it's on our border so madam speaker i
think what you're telling me is that my
time is up um and
i look forward to uh colleagues
questions thank you questions and
comments you all remember calgary
shepherd thank you madam speaker like to
thank the member for scarborough
guildwood for a
great intervention in the house i i've
had the honor of serving with him at the
foreign affairs committee a few
parliaments ago and i think there's a
lot of wisdom to the words he brings to
the house that it is in our national
interest to ensure
that the government of ukraine remains
independent has territorial integrity is
able to stand up to russian aggression
um i want to just add to a few things
that he said you know in 2015 when
russia attacked ukraine they used about
a dozen battalion tactical groups today
we're talking about up to 76 battalion
tactical groups massing on the border is
the types of troops that are being
massed in the board of ukraine that
indicate that they are serious about
entering ukrainian territory and staying
in ukraine terry for whatever purpose
for over length of time i wonder if the
member can uh can i expand on the
comments that he's made and what this
would mean for our national interests
for the national interest of nato allies
in the region as well
calgary guildwood i'm sorry scarborough
scarborough i must have moved madam
speaker uh
the um
the honorable member asks a
very uh
disturbing question and the reason that
it's disturbing is that this is a
buildup like nothing else we've ever
seen
and i think that
it is
has been appropriate that the family of
nations particularly the nato nations
have reacted as swiftly as they have in
a variety of ways
and
and i like him share
that concern i
would like to think that diplomacy would
do the trick here
i would like to think that this is a
faint or something of that nature that
this is just to uh to
trick the nato allies i'm not as
convinced
questions and comments
questions
thank you
i thank
my
honorable member from
the block she's my favorite
block member on the defense committee
[Music]
and i appreciate her question i
i would like to share her optimism about
the utility of diplomacy
um but if you if you are
interacting with a person who has a
delusional sense
of what constitute
russia's rightful
territorial area of influence
you're starting in a pretty deep hole
and it's it's difficult to arrive at an
agreed upon statement of threat if you
will an agreed upon statement of fact
and if you had those agree agreements or
some basis for moving forward on
diplomacy i would be
100 enthusiastic but i don't think that
this is at this time this is going to
work
uh and we have time for a brief question
the honor member for elmore transcona
yes
the the troop built up by russia along
the ukrainian border is completely
unacceptable as is its uh threatening
posture
uh towards ukraine and canada should
absolutely be coming to ukraine's
assistance and using
uh whatever tools it can including the
magnesia
sanctions which is something that
the government has has yet to do and i'm
wondering if the member has thoughts
about
why canada has yet to deploy magnitsky x
sanctions
as a tool to deter russia and and
whether we can expect that the
government will in the near future
answer from the member first carburetor
guildman thank you madam speaker and
thank the honourable member for his
excellent question
i agree with him completely
bill browder who is the
father of magnitsky sanctions said in
last week that
we need we meaning all of the nato
nations need to align the magnitsky
sanctions with each other because the
gaps is where where the russians win so
uh insofar as canada has not aligned
with other nations i would encourage
alignment
and i'd also encourage other nations to
align with the initiatives that canada
has taken on magnitsky because
as router rightly says
these
these people that are hiding money in
canada
in plain sight frequently
um have gotten it from
abuse of human rights and we should
under no circumstances tolerate uh those
kinds of investments in our country
resuming debate the honourable member
for vancouver center
thank you madam chair um
i've been listening with a great deal of
interest to all of the speakers and i
think that
i want to speak to constituents out
there
we all understand the issue you know the
regional i'm sorry i'm i'm just
wondering does the owner remember have
her head set on does she have her boom
down i just can't tell okay so
that will be very helpful to us here in
the house
is it plugged in
it is can you hear me
um there seems to be a little bit of an
issue from what i can see and it's not
quite clear
can you hear me now yeah that's i think
better right
is it good thanks yes i i have to put it
up just under my nose
well we're just going to check with the
with the interpreters uh can you keep
talking for a second
uh i will
keep talking
you don't have no you're absolutely
right john you don't have to ask me to
speak
i am delighted to speak at all times
we
okay go ahead
thank you very much madam chair i think
i wanted to speak to
the canadians out there and constituents
because i've noted that a lot of them
have been asking why is canadore
worrying about this country it's so far
away it's right out there up in eastern
europe why are we bothered and i think
we're bothered because this is not just
about about us it's not just about
ukraine it's not just about nato it's
not just about europe
it's about the fact that one has to have
a rules-based order
to keep global security moving one has
to be have relationships with countries
based on trust and what is shown is that
when in 1991 ukraine became a sovereign
nation or became independent
um it still carried the third largest
arms
arm supply in the world
and the agreement made
in 1994 at the organization for security
and corporation in europe uh called the
budapest agreement
was to give assurances where we wanted
they were everyone wanted to look at
nuclear disarmament and of course there
was an agreement between the united
kingdom and the united states and russia
and ukraine and kazakhstan as well that
actually said that if ukraine got rid of
all of its nuclear um storage that in
fact uh they would all agree that
ukraine as a sovereign nation
would have in exchange the ability to be
protected not to have any aggression
level against it its territorial
integrity and its sovereignty would be
accepted and realized well russia broke
that
it broke that rule when it went into
crimea in 2014.
it broke that rule again when it's
amassing troops on the borders of
ukraine and actually along the baltic
states it broke that rule and as john
mccain said uh sorry when the honourable
member for scarborough said uh it's now
looking at arming the baltic with
warships
russia is giving us a message
and the whole issue is about trust if we
cannot trust words if we cannot trust
agreements if we cannot trust assurances
then absolutely global security is at
risk when there is absolutely no trust
there and so we all need to be concerned
of it all of us we talked a lot here
about wanting peaceful solutions we
talked a lot here about not moving into
war but the way to prevent war is to
have trust the way to prevent war is to
have a rules-based world order the way
to prevent war is to make sure that we
can believe in each other and trust each
other's word russia has put in itself
not to be capable of doing that and not
only is it in 2014 when it moved into
crimea we know that it's moved into
transnistria we know that the baltic
states are all very very concerned and i
think that this is something we need to
think about i recall a time
when uh i don't know many of you
probably remember in history when a
certain government said that it would
only move in to take over czechoslovakia
and we believe them
and we agreed and we thought that was
all fine and wasn't that wonderful and
then we saw the move to take over all of
europe and then came the second world
war
we are at the brink of a global war we
need to think about it now obviously we
need to negotiate obviously we need to
try and find peaceful resolution to
conflict but we also need to have an
iron fist in a velvet glove as we talk
about the the kinds of things that we
need to do in terms of negotiating we
need to have solidly in our backpack
pardon my mixed metaphors in our
backpack things such as magnifice
mcnisky sanctions we need to understand
that money is being hidden in our
countries by oligarchs and by putin
himself that money came from corruption
it came from human rights uh
denials of many people around the world
this is a government that we need to
stop where it hurts in the pocketbook
and into the personal pocketbook if that
doesn't work we need to think about the
fact that we as members of the osce and
members of nato have to be prepared to
take whatever steps we need churchill
said um it is better to draw jaw than to
war war but sometimes as he showed us
we have to do what is necessary to
protect the global security thank you
very much
friends and comments questions
for calgary center a calorie shepherd
that's okay i was looking at the
side that that's okay when i'm speaker
i know that it's late in the hour now
and we've had a lot of these take note
uh speeches back and forth so i'd just
like to thank the member for the
contribution to this debate um i guess
i'm going to sound like the one was
maybe a softer tone i'm always worried
that when we do comparisons to world war
ii we're not getting it right this isn't
the soviet union anymore it's still the
same type of russian leadership that
we're seeing though that their their uh
default stance is to be hyper aggressive
towards us neighbors we saw them do this
exactly to georgia uh just a few well a
few years ago now it feels like but it's
been almost 15 years since that
particular conflict happen and since
then they've created two of these uh
autonomous separate kind of republics
that nobody else recognizes i wonder if
the member would comment on what the
possible interests would be from the
russian federation in trying to either
dismember ukraine or destabilize it
because we in canada as many cabinet
ministers have been mentioning have been
doing we've been contributing a lot to
the humanitarian and civil institution
uh strengthening effort in ukraine
be our member vancouver center thank you
madam chair madam speaker what i wanted
to say is that i am talking about the
word trust here
uh we trusted
a government who told us they were only
going into czechoslovakia and they
wouldn't do anything else and then they
moved to take over europe
i don't know what's at the at the bottom
line of putin's uh agenda but i do know
that he has shown himself not to be
trustworthy when he went into crimea
when he's arming his warships in the
baltic uh when he is threatening by his
very presence a lot of the baltic states
and uh
and the arctic ocean i think we need to
remember that we have to be guarded we
shouldn't be naive enough to believe
that whatever we are hearing from
somebody who has shown himself not to be
trusted that we need to be prepared we
need to start softly but we need to draw
job but we also need to be prepared and
i'm not going to say to war but we need
to be prepared to show our strength to
come together as members of nato with
the osce
thank you
questions and comments they are a member
for elmore transcona
thank you very much
they said earlier i mean the the buildup
of troops by russia along the ukrainian
border is not acceptable i think it is
important that canada
work with our allies to send a very
strong message about the fact that that
isn't acceptable but i've been i have
been troubled to see the extent to which
some of our allies you know are not
always inviting canada to the table it
seems
in uh in some of the important
discussions around a coordinated
response and i think of the fact that
you know for many years now under many
governments canada has failed to renew
its its uh its uh military equipment um
and so we've got a very you know we've
got very aged equipment in our in our
own case uh in terms of uh in terms of
gross national income canada's foreign
aid budget is actually quite low
and i think it's important that if
canada wants to play a real role in
these conversations and have a seat at
the table
that it recognized that it has to be on
an ongoing basis
um renewing its its it's it's equipment
for the men and women and the canadian
armed forces and also uh making sure
that it's that it's an active
participant on the world stage when it
comes to providing aid and support to
other countries that's part of the
infrastructure that a country needs in
order to be taken seriously around these
tables and something that canada had
developed throughout the course of the
second world war which was a reference
that the honorable member had made in
her own remarks so i'm just wondering if
she'd like to comment on on how it is
that canada finds itself i think
struggling to get
recognition at international tables in a
way that it used to and what we can
actually
do in order to make sure that uh the
canadian name has the same force and and
value and presence that it has had uh
historically throughout the um 20th
century
well the remember for vancouver center
thank you
madam speaker um look canada is at the
table canada is at the table with nato
playing the role that canada can and is
asked to play uh around that table
canada is playing at the table at the
organization for security and
cooperation in europe which is made up
of 57 nation states canada is well
respected and trusted and at that table
these are the people that are talking
about what are the steps to do to deal
with russia these are the people who
live close to russia they know what to
do so canada is also a close friend and
ally of the united states we are at the
table we've been at the table ever since
we've been dealing with osce agreements
that included russia and that included
kazakhstan and that included ukraine but
we are playing the role that we can play
when you're in a team you're asked to
play a certain role and we're doing that
at the moment this is a role that we
feel and that everyone has felt is a
good role for us to play we're prepared
i'm sure to move forward if we're asked
to play other rules but canada is
definitely at the table and i know
because i'm very involved in the
organization for security and
cooperation in europe
the honorable
member
thank you very much madam speaker i'd
like to thank all of my colleagues
who've stayed so late um
i think it shows as many of my
colleagues
what the government hasn't done in its
response
diplomacy and persuasion are very
important that have been brought up
but if those efforts are not coordinated
that it's very harsh
that diplomacy should be the main weapon
to find a solution to this crisis
in our
has
diplomacy
accused of not having a clear strategy
for its diplomacy
criticized
there have been five ministers in six
years of uh
our foreign to foreign affairs has
changed with the change in minister and
staff so in the context of the crisis
with ukraine
canada can't stand idly
[Music]
[Music]
before the cart if you want to go
forward and it seems like right now
canada's a little bit the cart before
the horses if you will
not only
problematic
issues
have is that
uh when we do things sometimes
by others and in other cases
maybe some contradictions
doesn't send the right message we're
sending troops
that mission would be uh cancelled and
these troops would be taken out because
they're not trained
uh or not ready to fight and that um
so we might not be ready for that
situation
military action but it's being presented
as if it were a response to a possible
russian invasion
the thing that canada has done is
military
the basis for that it does seem to be a
bit of a slap in the face to ukraine who
has been asking specifically for
military support but it seems like once
again we're sending a message to say
that you know we'll help you
but we're hoping that there won't be a
crisis
money will help you know the economy
because there is a russian threat to the
economy and that
destabilizing the country but if the
crisis were to get worse well that money
wouldn't be used to fight uh the russian
threat
once again
there seems to be uh i think a bit of an
incoherence
[Music]
that are coming out here
uh to provide a military equipment so
again without getting into a debate on
the merits of that we have
a democracy
is
but at the same time we're still sending
weapons to saudi arabia
so the question is why are we sending
weapons to saudi arabia but we're not
sending it into ukraine so again without
getting into the debate on uh
the merits of that action these measures
you know have
message the message that canada is
sending isn't it
he's demonstrated a number of problems
with canada's uh diplomacy so once again
canada seems to have a bit too much of
an attitude
the impression that foreign policy is
one of his priorities
and this
who
excuse me
according to a former uh
[Music]
that's also unfortunate to say
the prime minister continues to name
deputy ministers for foreign affairs who
have never served as uh
its moral compass again when it comes to
foreign affairs
but uh despite that uh canada's foreign
policy hasn't been to a serious release
since 2005. so what i'd like to bring to
this debate tonight
is i want to make sure
to make sure that we have
you you can't build credibility in one
day and that's certainly the case in the
time of crisis so madam speaker i think
that this evening is the time to note
that there's still work to be done and i
hope
that that's will what will come out of
this evening's debate thank you very
much questions and comments the
honourable member for etobicoke center
thank you thank you very much madam
speaker and i'd like to thank my
colleague for her speech
she highlighted certain aspects of our
diplomacy where she believes that there
are
[Music]
and that's why there are certain
individuals like president biden
and in terms of the loan of 120 million
dollars
to
ukraine stabilization
the goal there was to stabilize their
financial system and uh again that's
impossible
when it comes to
uh suggest that we should also be
sending weapons to ukraine
is
and in this context we want to make sure
that we're sending a
that would have a concrete impact i
think it'd be more important in terms of
the signal that we'd be sending and we
need to make sure we're sending clear
scenes
calgary shepard thank you madam speaker
uh
um
um
a
federation
is
of weapons but i think that that should
be
subsequent to uh diplomatic efforts and
these things can be done in parallel and
they must be done in parallel because if
we send weapons we need to make sure
that the message we're sending is clear
because we could
uh send military
everything is being done in parallel
saying that we should create a hierarchy
of the order in which things should be
done or could be done
but i think things should be done in
parallel at the same time the honourable
member for london cancer
thank you madam speaker and i would also
like to ask the question in french but i
don't know if i would communicate as
effectively especially at this late hour
first so i'm going to stick to english
forgive me i'll work on it um one of the
questions that i asked earlier in the in
the debate of the conservative our
conservative colleague on the defense
committee it is another i'd like to ask
my honorable colleague in the in the
block and i do appreciate her her work
on the defense committee as well it's
been good so far um working together
but ultimately uh there has been a huge
lack of liberal leadership um when it
comes to the men and women who are
serving in the armed forces uh there is
a lot of doubt about whether it's safe
um
women who have served their and are
giving up their entire careers because
they cannot go forward and so we've
talked about that retention that
recruitment problem um and this puts an
additional stress on uh the women as we
expand and and amplify uh the mission uh
with uh unifier so i would like to hear
her comments her thoughts on what we
need to do
from from our end to uh better support
the men and women of the the canadian
armed forces and to ensure that the
liberal party and the liberal government
does the same thank you
to the honorable member
thank
you i'd like to thank my colleagues
we do work well together at the defense
committee
that has been a bit uh
major issue we need to make sure that
we're ready to help as we can but we
won't be able to do that if we don't
have anybody left in the armed forces
and this is definitely an issue
questions and comments questions and
comments
you